PART OF THE COMMITTEE'S ONGOING
RESPONSIBILITY TO EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT. OF AGE AGENCIES UNDER
THEIR JURISDICTION THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF THIS REVIEW IS TO
ASSESS THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
EFFICIENCY. OF THESE AGENCIES IN
PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND TO
DETERMINE WHETHER CHANGES IN THE
OVERALL OR IN THEIR OPERATIONS
TODAY WE WILL BE REVIEWING
SPECIFIC ISSUES REGARDING THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARD.
DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE OF THE
CALIBER OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. TO ASSIST MEMBERS IN
THE REVIEW AND EVALUATION OF
EACH AGENCY COMMITTEE PREPARED
BACKGROUND PAPERS WHICH
IDENTIFIES ISSUES AND MAKE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE. THESE PAPERS
PAPERS HAVE BEEN POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AND MADE
AVAILABLE TO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. WE WILL ASK EACH
PROGRAM TO BEGIN THEIR TESTIMONY
WITH BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THEIR
FUNCTIONS AND RESPOND TO STAFF.
TO RESPOND TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED BY STAFF IN THE ANALYSIS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ALSO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE ANY
OTHER ISSUES OR QUESTIONS WHICH
THEY MAY HAVE. WE WILL ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FOR EACH PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. LIKE TO.
INVITE IN WELCOME OUR GOOD
FRIEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER EER KNOW
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE TO. MAKE HIS OPENING
COMMENTS.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTERED ON THE YOU VERY MUCH
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ALSO ALSO JOINED US HERE. FOR
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH RESPECT
OUR JOINT SUNSET REVIEW HEARING
SAID THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THERE WILL BE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO ALSO GIVE OTHER
COMMENTS LATER ON SO THERE WILL
BE A PROCESS FOR THAT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A A CHAIR LOW IN THE.
I THINK WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE
ACUPUNCTURE PORTRAYED SO FIRST
OFF ABOUT WE WILL. INVITE OUR
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD TO PLEASE COME
UP TO THE DYESS OF FOR YOUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND AGAIN
PUBLIC COMMENTS WILL BE. A
WELCOME TO THEIR AFTER OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND OF COURSE
WE'LL HAVE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES TO BE DISCUSSED.
AND FIRST.
FOR THE THREE MEMBERS THAT WE
HAVE HERE I'M DOCTOR A MEME
TECHIE BOARD PRESIDENT KIDMAN
CHAN BOARD VICE PRESIDENT. AND
BENJAMIN BUT DATA EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD SO UP.
WHICHEVER VIEW WHICH IS TO BEGIN
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
.
GOOD MORNING HONORABLE COMMITTEE
CHAIRS SENATOR JERRY HILL AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW. AND
GOOD MORNING TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE JOINT COMMITTEES IT IS A
TRULY HONORED TO COME BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
MY NAME IS A DOCTOR A MEME A
TECHIE. I AM A LICENSED THE
PHYSICIAN AND THE SURGEON ALSO
LICENSE THE ACUPUNCTURIST AND I
AM THE PRESIDENT OF ACUPUNCTURE
BORED. WITH ME TODAY OF MY
COLLEAGUES. BOARD VICE PRESIDENT
MISS THE CAVEMAN CHAN. AND BOARD
EXECUTIVE OFFICER MISTER
BENJAMIN BOLIVIA.
THE COMMITTEE HAVE IDENTIFIED A
THREE USED TO USE THAT AS THEY
WOULD LIKE FOR US TO TO ADDRESS
TODAY.
FIRST SCHOOL APPROVAL SECOND THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE LICENSING
EXAM AND THE THIRD. THE BORDER
LICENSE TO PUBLIC A MEMBER
RATIO.
BEFORE WE ADDRESS THE ISSUES WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE GUN OF A
PRESENTATION WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE ACUPUNCTURE
BOARD.
THE BOARD HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE THE PRACTICE OF
ACUPUNCTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BOARDING ISSUES ONE TYPE OF
A LICENSE ACUPUNCTURIST.
ACUPUNCTURE IS A DEFINING
STATUTE AS OF THE STIMULATION OF
A CERTAIN POINT ALL POINTS ON OR
NEAR THE SURFACE OF THE BODY. BY
THE INSERTION OF THE NEEDLES TO
PREVENT A MODIFY THE PERCEPTION
OF THE PAIN ALL TO NORMALIZE THE
PHYSIOLOGICAL FUNCTIONS
INCLUDING PAIN CONTROL FOR THE
TREATMENT OF CERTAIN DISEASES.
ALL THESE FUNCTIONS OF THE BODY.
AND IT INCLUDES THE TECHNIQUE OF
THE ELECTRO ACUPUNCTURE COPYING
AND A BOX OF BOSTON.
THE ACUPUNCTURE PROFESSION HAS
BEEN REGULATED IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
THE BOARD IS A COMPRISE THE OFF
FULL PUBLIC COMMANDERS AND THE
THREE LICENSE THE MEMBERS.
THERE IS A PRESENTLY A VACANCY
OFF OUR LICENSE THE MEMBER.
OF A STAFF CONSISTS OF BANK
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. NINE
PERMANENT STAFF AND A THREE PART
TIME STAFF.
THE BOARD PERFORMS THE FOLLOWING
FUNCTIONS.
LICENSING EXAMINATION
ENFORCEMENT CONTINUE EDUCATION
OVERSIGHT. TRAINING PROGRAM OF
CURRICULUM APPROVAL.
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION AND A
REGULATORY IMPLEMENTATION.
THE BOARD HAS A BUDGET OF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND
IS THE RESERVES.
AT FULL POINT A ONE MILLION
DOLLARS.
CURRENTLY THE BORDER REGULATES A
TOTALOF TWELVE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO ACTIVE LICENSE
ACUPUNCTURIST.
PULL MY REQUIRED TO RENEW THEIR
LICENSES EVERY TWO YEARS TO
COMPLETE FIFTY UNITS A
CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR YOU TO
BRING YOUR WILL.
THE BOARD'S MISSION AS A TO
PROTECT. BENEFIT ADDING INFORM
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA BY
EXERCISING THE LICENSING
REGULATORY. ENFORCEMENTS
MANDATES OF THE ACUPUNCTURE
LICENSE YOUR BACK.
WE WILL NOW PRESENT ON THE THREE
ISSUES OUTLINED BY COMMITTEES.
THE FIRST ITEM WILL BE USED TO
NUMBER SIX.
SCHOOL APPROVAL.
THIS WILL BE ADDRESSED BY OF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER MISSED THE
BOAT DO. PLEASE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR A TECHIE. GOOD
MORNING.
THE BOARD HAS BEEN ASKED TO
UPDATE THE COMMITTEES ON THE
STATUS OF THE SCHOOL APPROVAL
PROCESS.
THE BOARD HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE TWO ADDITIONAL AGENCIES
NOW REQUIRED AS PART OF
ACUPUNCTURE TRAINING PROGRAM
APPROVAL. CALIFORNIA'S BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
OR BPP. AND THE ACCREDITATION
COMMISSION FOR ACUPUNCTURE AND
ORIENTAL MEDICINE OR A COLUMN.
THE BOARD HAS DEVELOPED OPEN
COMMUNICATION CHANNELS AND
RESPONSE OF PROTOCOLS SUCH THAT
WE CAN SHARE RELEVANT
INFORMATION TO SATISFY EACH OF
OUR ROLES. IN THE APPROVAL
ENFORCEMENT OF APPROVED
ACUPUNCTURE TRAINING PROGRAMS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BOARD STAFF
AND MEMBERS MET WITH BPP AND A
CALM REPRESENTATIVES ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS TO UNDERSTAND THE
SEPARATE PROCESSES EACH ARE
CHARGED WITH.
THE BOARD AND A CALM AS WELL AS
THE BOARD AND BE PP HAVE
OBSERVED OTHERS EACH OTHER SITE
VISIT PROCESS AND ALL THREE
AGENCIES HAVE WORKED TOGETHER ON
ENFORCEMENT MATTERS.
THE BOARD DOES NOT HAVE ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES WITH A CALM
OR PPP.
BOARD STAFF HAVE IDENTIFIED
STATUTORY LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM AMENDMENT TO
IMPROVE PUBLIC PROTECTION. THESE
ITEMS WILL BE BROUGHT BEFORE THE
BOARD TO CONSIDER.
IN THE SUMMER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
FOR ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT THE
COMMITTEES HAVE ASKED THAT THE
BOARD ADDRESSED SEVERAL ITEMS
REGARDING THE CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE LICENSING EXAM. OR
KALE.
THE FIRST QUESTION ASKED THAT
THE BOARD DISCUSSED THE
FEASIBILITY COST AND TIME
CONSTRAINTS RELATED TO SWITCHING
THE CALEB TO COMPUTER BASED
TESTING.
THE BOARD AGREES WITH THE
COMMITTEES THAT COMPUTER BASED
TESTING WOULD BE AN EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT UPGRADE.
THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR CONTINUOUS
ADAPTIVE ON DEMAND TESTING AS
OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF
PENCIL AND PAPER. EXAMS HELD
TWICE A YEAR.
HIGH SECURITY AND TESTING
STANDARDS WOULD BE MAINTAINED I
WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR GREATER
ACCESSIBILITY BY OFFERING
MULTIPLE TESTING SITES AVAILABLE
YEAR ROUND.
THE BOARD HAS SUBMITTED THE
APPLICATION. TO INITIATE THE
MOVE TO COMPUTER BASED TESTING
WITH THE DC IS OFFICE OF
INFORMATION SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD CONTINUES
TO MEET WITH THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONALEXAMINATION
SERVICES OR OP S. FOR THEIR
INPUT AND CONTRACT REQUIREMENTS.
THIS PROCESS BEGAN IN THE FALL
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND WILL
TAKE TWELVE TO EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
THE COST OF SWITCHING TO
COMPUTER BASED TESTING HAVE YET
TO BE DETERMINED.
THE BOARD ANTICIPATES THAT
COMPUTER BASED TESTING WILL
LOWER THE COST TO ADMINISTER THE
KALE. WITH THE COST OF
DEVELOPING THE KALE REMAINING
THE SAME.
THE COMMITTEES HAVE OSCAR THE
BOARD TO DISCUSS THE FEASIBILITY
COST AND THE TIME CONSTRAINTS
RELATED TO DEVELOPING A
CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENT TO THE
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION
COMMISSION. FOR ACUPUNCTURE AND
ORIENTAL MEDICINE ALL NCC A O.
M. EXAMINATION. OF FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE RECIPROCITY.
ASTHE BACKGROUND PAPER NOTED.
AFTER REVIEWING OLD P. S. AUDIT
OF THE NCC OAM EXAMINATIONS IN
JUNE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THE
BOARD VOTED TO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION THAT A WOODED
TRANSLATION THE KILL. TWO THE
NCC A LAMB WITHOUT CALIFORNIA
SUPPLEMENTAL EXAMINATION. NOT TO
TAKE PLACE BEFORE JANUARY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN.
O. P. S. IS THE PROCESS TO
REVIEW THE NC C. A. O. M.'S MOST
THE RECENT JOB TASK ANALYSIS.
WHICH WILL PROVIDE A CLEAR
PICTURE OF HOW TO DEVELOP A
CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENTAL EXAM.
THE BOARD NEEDS TO DISCUSS
VISIBILITY TO ADDRESS UNRESOLVED
ISSUES. FOR THE ISSUES ARE
RESOLVED WE WILL REACH OUT TO
OTHER BOARDS THAT HAVE DEVELOPED
THEIR OWN CALIFORNIA
SUPPLEMENTAL EXAMS. TO DEVELOP
POLICIES AND. AND REGULATIONS
UNNECESSARY FULL IMPLEMENTATION.
THE OVERALL COST AND THE LENGTH
OF TIE NEEDED TO DEVELOP A
CALIFORNIA SUPPLEMENTAL EXAM
IT'S A YET TO BE DETERMINED.
THE BOARD HAS A NOTED
DISCREPANCIES IN THE TOTAL COST
TO APPLICANTS HAD TO TAKE ALL
FALL MODULES OF THE NCC A O. M..
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL FACE TO
PROVIDE OF THOSE EXAMINATION
RESULTS TO THE BOARD FOR
QUALIFICATION FOR LICENSE FOR.
THESE CONCERNS HAS BEING
ADDRESSED BY THE BOARD AT
SEVERAL MEETINGS INCLUDING THE
JUNE TWO THOUSAND A SIXTEEN
MEETING. AT A REMAIN UNRESOLVED.
THE BOARD OF FIRMS THAT'S THE
COST OF TWO APPLICANTS FOR THE
KILL. IS SIX HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS.
THE COMMITTEES HAVE OSCAR THE
BOARD TO DISCUSS THE FEASIBILITY
COST AT A TIME CONSTRAINS
RELATED TO WORKING NATIONALLY
WITH OTHER STATES AND THE
POTENTIAL LATELY. FEDERAL
HEALTHCARE AGENCIES TO UN KRIZ
THE PORTABILITY'S OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE LICENSE
AND THE IMPROVE RECIPROCITY.
THE OTHER OUT OF THE STATE TO
LICENSE.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A NATIONAL
STANDARDS FOR ACUPUNCTURE
EDUCATION AT A PRACTICE.
EACH STATE SETS THEIR OWN
SPECIFIC STANDARDS. AS THE
BACKGROUND OF PAPER NOTES. THERE
ARE SIXTEEN STATES THAT A
LICENSED ACUPUNCTURIST WITH THE
RE RECOGNIZED OUT OF A STATE
LICENSE AND I ABLE TO UNDER
MINISTER. RECIPROCAL LICENSING
AGREEMENTS.
THE BOARD HAS THE DISCUSSED AND
A DIRECTOR BORDER STAFF. TO
RESEARCH OTHER STATES A
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS AND THE
POSSIBILITIES OF A WORKING WITH
OTHER STATES TO US UP TO THE
KILL. ALL THE CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE LICENSE.
WITH THE U. TWO STATES IN
FORCING THEIR OWN STANDARDS.
THERE MAY BE THE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
LICENSEES TO PASS A BAN TO
STATES SUPPLEMENTAL EXAMINATION.
IN CALIFORNIA APPLICANTS ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE.
MOVED TO THREE THOUSAND OUR
CURRICULUM. AT HAVE PROVED A
TRAINING PROGRAM. MANY STAYS. AT
NINETEEN HUNDRED HOURS.
THE BOARDS AND NEEDS TO DISCUSS
THE FEASIBILITY COST AT A TIME
CONSTRAINTS NECESSARY TO
INCREASE THE PORTABILITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE LICENSE.
AND IMPROVE RECIPROCITY WITH
OTHER OUT OF THE STATE LICENSE.
LIST THE TEN WILL ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE THIRD ITEM.
YEAH I USED TO THIRTEEN THE
LICENSE. TO PALM BEACH BOARD
MEMBER RACIAL.
THIS USUAL PASTA BOUGHT THE
RATIO TO LICENSE DEPARTMENT
MEMBER SHOULD BE A TEST THAT.
YES NO YOU NOW UP OVER BE ABLE
SUPPORT HAS COME RICE.
FREE LIES SOME MEMBERS AND FOR
POPPING MEMBERS.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY A VACANCY FOR
A GOVERNOR APPOINTED LICENSE
MEMBER.
THE USUAL HAS NOT BEEN BOUGHT UP
BY THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
REASON FOR MEETING.
THE BOARD WILL COME AND SEEING
THE INPUT FROM THE LICENSE.
THIS.
THANK THANK YOU THOSE ARE THREE
ISSUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOW WE'VE
NOW. COMPLETED THE UP COMMENTS
FROM A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARD AND
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE BMP COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS THE. ASSEMBLY BEING P.
COMMITTEE NOW OPENING ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MANY
MEMBERS HERE IN THE COMMITTEE SO
FIRST UP WAS THAT WITH SENATOR
PENN ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO AND THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KEITH. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH CHAIR LOW AND I
THINK SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
AT A FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP IN THE ANALYSIS
OF THE FIRST OF ALL ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT SEEMS TO BE RUNNING
THROUGH IS IS THE.
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF STAFFING.
ANDERS COMING ABOUT THE. LACK
OF DISCIPLINE AND GET YOUR
DOCTOR AND NO OTHER YOU KNOW NO.
MATTER IS IT.
SO I WANNA BE CLEAR AND I
CLARIFIED THESE IT SEEMS LIKE
IMPLIES THAT YOU TROUBLE HIRING
SO YOU HAVE THE POSITION YOU
JUST CAN'T HIRE INTO IT OR DO
YOU HAVE THE POSITIONS. OURS OR
AN ABSENCE OF POSITION ITSELF
THAT WAS ENTIRELY CLEAR ANALYSIS
TO ME. BUT LET ME CLARIFY DOCTOR
FOUND.
WE DO NOT HAVE AUTHORITY FOR
THAT POSITION RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
SUBMITTED A B. C. P. THAT HAS
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AND IT
IS GOING TO BE BEFORE THE
SUPPORT COMMITTEE IN APRIL. ADS
ON BE SURE FOR EXAMPLE IF THAT
IS IN PLACE WE SHOULD
COMMUNICATE OR SPECS OF BUDGET
COMMITTEES TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT I SO WANT TO
TOUCH ON IS.
.
YOU KNOW BEING A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL MYSELF I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO STAY ON TOP
OF THINGS AND.
.
YEAH I AM VERY DISTURBED THAT
THAT.
THERE BEEN NO KIDDING EDUCATION.
TARGETS FOR THREE YEARS AND.
SO.
AND THEY SAID BEGAN BECAUSE OF
VACANCIES WHICH I ACTUALLY I
DON'T FIND ACCEPTABLE.
YOU KNOW THAT'S BEEN A REQUEST
SHOULD'VE BEEN MADE I MEAN FOR
THREE YEARS THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
ODD IT'S.
AND YOU SAID EXPECTED TO RESUME
OUT IT'S A REAL LIFE SUPPORT
WRITTEN ARE THOSE AUDITS NOW.
I'M GOING NOW.
WE HAVE REVISED THE ENTIRE SEA
OTTER PROCESS STREAMLINED AND
TRAINED STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
REVIEW AND WE HAVE SELECTED THE
NAMES GOING BACK TO TE TWENTY.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN FISCAL YEAR THE
BOARD IS ALLOWED.
IT REQUIRES LICENSEES TO KEEP
THEIR CERTIFICATES FOR FOUR
YEARS WERE ABLE TO GO BACK THAT
FAR IN THE AUDITING PROCESS AND
WE'RE ABLE TO RESUME FROM WHERE
WE LEFT OFF. YOUR RESUMING RIGHT
NOW CORRECT. OKAY.
THE OTHER ISSUE ALSO IN TERMS
OF CONTINUING EDUCATION. AS I
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE BOARD
ALSO APPROVES THE CD PROVIDERS
OF COURSE IS CORRECT THAT IS
CORRECT.
SO WHEN THE THINGS THAT.
YOU MENTIONED IS IS THAT.
YOU KNOW THERE'S I GUESS
THERE'S A FLAT FEE OF A HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLARS PER PROVIDER BUT
YOU HAVE SOME PROVIDERS
PROVIDING. LOTS OF COURSES AND
SOME PROVIDING A FEW.
AND I PRESUME. I MEAN AND THEN
THE OTHER PART IS COMMENTED ON
WAS IS THAT WHILE THERE ARE
LEGAL STANDARDS. REGARDS TO.
.
YOU KNOW CONFLICT OF INTEREST
AND.
WHICH IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE I THINK I COULD YOU
EDUCATION SHOULD NOT BE A SALES
JOB. UNFORTUNATELY. YOU KNOW
I'VE SEEN THAT HAPPEN WHERE
SOMEONE THEY CALL IT CONTINUING
EDUCATION IT'S SELLING A PRODUCT
THAT THEY'RE PROFITING FROM.
SO WE NEED TO BE VERY ON TOP OF
THAT.
THAT BASICALLY IT'S A COMPLAINT
BASED SYSTEM AND WE'RE NOT
ACTIVELY PURSUING AND LIKE
REQUIRING PEOPLE TO SUBMIT
WHAT'S THE COURSE CONTENT IS.
WHAT THEIR DECLARATIONS FOR
CONFLICT ARE ADVERTISEMENTS
RELATE TO THOSE COURSES?
SO BEING MUCH MORE PRO ACTIVE
ABOUT IT INSTEAD OF PASSIVE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW FRANKLY MOST
THE PEOPLE WHO GO.
THEY SEE SOMETHING. THAT THEY
THINK MAYBE SHADY DELL EITHER
GO.
THERE MAY BE SOME INCENTIVES TO
GO EVEN OF PRIDE YOU FREE DINNER
OR WILL PAY YOU KNOW YOU GET
THERE SOMETHING I MEAN THOSE ARE
TYPES OF THINGS. THAT THAT.
THEY'LL BE VERY CONCERNING AND
THAT'S YOU AND EXPECTS ME TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT THAT.
SO WHAT IS BEING DONE TO TRY TO
TO BE MUCH MORE PROACTIVE ANSWER
SIMPLY WAITING FOR COMPLAINTS
AND THEN SECOND OF ALL. YOU KNOW
AGAIN.
NOW IF YOU ARE AUDITING AND FOR
THREE YEARS.
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF STAFF
ONLY TO DO IT AND THEN THE OTHER
THINGS ARE YOU CONSIDERING
PERHAPS A PER COURSE FEE AND AS
WELL AS A PROVIDER FEE TO ENSURE
YOU HAVE TO. THE REVENUE
NECESSARY AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
RUNNING AT THAT DEFICIT EVEN
THOUGH YOU DO HAVE A FAIRLY
SUBSTANTIAL RESERVES. TO BE SURE
THAT YOU CAN SUPPORT THE THE
ENFORCEMENT THAT'S NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THE
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
I'LL START AT THE FIRST QUESTION
OF THE BOARD'S REGULATIONS DO
REQUIRE THAT SEE PROVIDERS WHEN
SUBMITTING A COURSE APPROVAL A
REQUEST DO. NOT SUBMIT THERE AT
ADVERTISEMENTS AND WE DO REVIEW
THE ADVERTISEMENTS THEY ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO IF THEY HAVE A
PRODUCT OF THEIR OWN. THE
REQUIRED TO TALK ABOUT THE
GENERAL GENERIC PRODUCT AS WELL.
SO THERE.
THEY'RE MADE TO DECLARE IF THAT
IS THE CASE IN THE APPLICATION.
THESE ARE REVIEWED IN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. OF THE
BOARD HAS DISCUSSED AND. IT HAS
BEEN DETERMINED IN EVEN IN THE
LAST BACKGROUND PAPER THAT THE
BOARD HAS THE AUTHORITY TO SET A
PER COURSE FEE AND STAFF IS
RESEARCHING THIS FOR A COST
ANALYSIS OF THE PROCESS.
SO IN TERMS OF BECAUSE YOU SAID
THAT SO YOU HAVE STEEP CURRENT
HAVE SUFFICIENT STAFF TO DO THAT
YET OR NOT. BUT NOT FOR THE
ADDITIONAL MONITORING THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT. WHAT I DESCRIBED
EARLIER IS WHAT WE CURRENTLY DO
WHAT WOULD BE MORE BENEFICIAL AS
FOR ADDITIONAL MONITORING OF
BEING ABLE TO SIT AND ON LIFE
COURSES EITHER BY? CONTRACTING
WITH SMES SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
OR BY BEING ABLE TO SIT IN ON
THE LIVE WEBINARS THERE ARE
VIEWED. BY OUR LICENSEES SO THIS
IS SOMETHING WE ARE LOOKING AT
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE PROPER STUFF TO DO
THAT.
AND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO OKAY SO
I MEAN I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY IMPORTANT I'M SURE MOST
PEOPLE ARE NOT FOLLOWING THE
RULES.
IT'S IT'S USUALLY YOU KNOW THAT
TRYING TO BE SURE WE. DRESS THE
BAD ACTORS ENDED ABOUT THERE
BECAUSE WE WE DON'T WANT TO.
HAVING.
.
COURSES THAT ARE NOT THAT MAY
BE IN CONFLICT ARE.
PROVIDE MISINFORMATION TO
PROVIDERS NOW.
THEIR PERSONAL GAIN.
THANK YOU.
AND THE MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT LET ME
FIRST START BY THANKING YOU FOR.
YOUR PRESENTATION AND I.
I AM HERE IN PART AS. SOMEONE
HIS FATHER'S AN ACUPUNCTURIST
AND SOME OF HIS BROTHER'S AN
ACUPUNCTURIST SO I HAVE.
CERTAINLY BEEN APPRISED OF FROM
THEM AND OTHERS ON SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU ARE GRAPPLING
WITH.
ONE OF THE ISSUES I CONTINUE TO
HEAR ABOUT ACUPUNCTURE IS JUST
THE CHALLENGES OF OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IN BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS. THE TYPE OF CARE THAT
YOUR PROFESSION IS PROVIDING A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND NUMBER
OF US ON THIS COMMITTEE. WORKING
WITH OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE WERE
ABLE TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
FUNNY TO THE MEDICAL PROCESS.
THAT HAD BEEN CUT DURING THE
GREAT RECESSION. BUT WE CONTINUE
TO HEAR PARTICULARLY FROM A LOW
INCOME.
RESIDENCE.
PARTICULAR FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES OF CHALLENGES OF
RECEIVING CARE. FROM YOUR
PROFESSION AND IT OCCURRED TO ME
AS I READ THE OVERVIEW OF THE
ISSUES AROUND. CHALLENGES IN
BALANCING THE BUDGET THE FAILURE
OF OR OR THE.
THE FACT THAT. THAT THAT THE
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD IS NOT YET ON%
THE PRE SYSTEM OF THE CHALLENGES
AROUND SCHOOL PREFOLDS.
THE CHALLENGES AS DOCTOR PAN
POINTED OUT AROUND THE LACK
ABOUT ITS AROUND CONTINUED
EDUCATION ALL OF THESE COULD
IMPACT THE ABILITY OF OF MAKING
SURE THAT. WE HAVE A PROFESSION
THAT IS IS READY TO PROVIDE THE
ACCESS THAT WE NEED FOR FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SOMEONE IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS WHAT YOU SEE AS
CHALLENGES AND.
AND WHAT YOU THINK WE OUGHT TO
BE DOING AS AS OVERSIGHT TO
ASSIST THE PROFESSION OF MOVING
IN THAT RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU MR TO.
OF.
THE PART I WANT TO SEE I AGREE
WITH THE CURRENTLY YOU HAVE
ADDRESSED THE BOARD REALLY HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE. OF THE
YEAR INSURANCE PART YOU KNOW
FULL OF THE PATIENTS THAT
THERE'S MANY OF THEM. IT IS THE
UNDERSERVED. I KNOW A LOT OF THE
ACCU PUNCTURES TODAY YOU KNOW
SCREWS THE.
WORKING.
TO SERVE THOSE PART OF THE
POPULATIONS AS YOU KNOW.
EDUCATION AND FREE EVEN TO GO
TO THE HOSPITAL IS TOO DIFFERENT
TO SERVICES. A WILL BE REALLY
HELPFUL OF FROM YOU KNOW THE.
LEGISLATURE TO HELP CONTINUE.
WORKING ON HOW TO. HELP TOO
FUNDING.
BE PAID IN THE FUTURE. OF FROM
ONE OF THE PARTY WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORKING I'LL. HELP
WITH THE CONTINUE EDUCATION
COURSES.
HELP TO. PROTECT OTHER CONSUMERS
IN A WAY IS.
LICENSING REGULATION MANDATE OF
ACUPUNCTURE ACT.
I MAY I THINK.
IF I MAY ADD OF THE ACT PERFECT
ACUPUNCTURE PROFESSION
NATIONALLY. HAS DIFFERENT
STANDARDS AS WE MENTIONED
EARLIER OUR VIEW THAT DOES MAKE
IT CHALLENGING IN TERMS OF A
NATIONAL LEVEL OF DELIVERY BUT
AS YOU SAID CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE
THAT IN THE MEDICAL SYSTEM.
.
Z..
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES INTERNALLY
WITH THE BOARD IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS I'VE FOCUSED ON
STREAMLINING OUR PROCESSES SO
THAT OUR INTERNAL PROCESSES DO
NOT HOLD UP THE. PUBLIC'S
PROTECTION IN ACUPUNCTURE AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO ENDEAVOR TO
STREAMLINE PROCESSES WE ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A BUSINESS PLAN OR
IS IT BUSINESS MOTIVATION PLAN
RIGHT NOW. WE ARE RELEASED THREE
CANDIDATE ON THE BREEZE SYSTEM
AND ALTHOUGH WE'VE BEEN PAYING
INTO IT FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS
IT ACTUALLY IS BEEN HELPFUL TO
HOLD OFF UNTIL RELEASED THREE
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN THE
CHALLENGES FOR RELEASES ONE AND
TWO IN THEIR IMPLEMENTATION. OF
MORE OVER THE.
COMMITTEES HAVE DIRECTED THE DC
EIGHT TO DO THIS BUSINESS MORE
EFFICIENT PLAN WHICH IS ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT OUR INTERNAL
PROCESSES RIGHT NOW. WE ARE
CURRENTLY MAPPING ARE AS IS
PROCESS ISN'T GOING TO BE MOVING
TOWARD TWO B. PROCESSES SEEKING
IMPLEMENTATION OF NEW SYSTEMS BY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. SO THIS IS I THINK VERY
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE. THE
PROPER BUSINESS TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO US TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SO THAT
NOTHING THAT HAPPENS INTERNALLY
IS HOLDING UP. THE PRACTICE OF
ACUPUNCTURE IN A SAFE SETTING IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD JUST.
IN I THINK THE ISSUES ARE A
BREEZE OR BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED
AND.
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
EIGHT AS DCA KNOWS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO TO. HELP IN A NUMBER OF
OUR PROFESSION SUCK IT UP
ONLINE.
I KNOW PART OF THE ANALYSIS.
YOUR BOARD IS VOTED TO
RECOMMEND INTRODUCING
INTRODUCTION OF LEGISLATION TO
REQUIRE APPLICANTS TO TAKE. ONE
TYPE OF AN EXAMINATION AND.
AGAIN I THINK THESE ARE ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO RESOLVE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE THE TOOLS TO THE
VET.
THE QUALIFICATION OF OF OF FOR
ACUPUNCTURISTS. I THINK MY FINAL
COMMENT IS FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
ACUPUNCTURE HAS ALWAYS BEEN IN
MANY INSTANCES A LOWER COST. WAY
OF PROVIDING.
POT IS THE TYPE OF HEALTH CARE
THAT. COULD OTHERWISE BE
EXPENSIVE IF PROVIDED THROUGH
OTHER MEANS.
BUT I THINK SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE FACING
WITH REGARDS TO THE PROFESSION
ARE HOLDING US BACK FROM REALLY
SEEN THAT VISION AND SO. LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION OF HOW WE ADDRESS
ALL THESE ISSUES IN THE OVERVIEW
SO THAT WE CAN. MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S ACTUALLY A REALITY.
AS A MEMBER GIBSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION.
THUS FAR.
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
INDUSTRY.
I FOR ONE HAVE NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE
AGRICULTURE.
BEFORE BECAUSE I'M AFRAID OF
NEEDLES SO DOES AS FREAKS ME OUT
TO BE HONEST HOWEVER NOT SO BAD.
HOWEVER.
THE BORDERS ISSUED.
.
A CERTAIN PARTICULAR.
DIRECTIVES AS RELATES TO AMEND
FOR CEMENT AND IN THIS SPACE. I
AM CONCERNED THAT THE AVERAGE
DAYS OF AN AVERAGE DAY. UP TO
PROCESS ACCUSATIONS AGAINST THE
LICENSES HAS INCREASED FROM FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE. UP IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN.
TO NINE HUNDRED AND TWO TWO AND
THE EFFORTS TWENTY OF FOURTEEN
OR FIFTEEN. AND ALSO THE
AVERAGE.
DAY.
TAKES A LONG TIME TO COMPLETE
AN INVESTIGATION FROM.
ANYWHERE FROM A THOUSAND EIGHTY
TWO.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN TO ELEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO TO TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN.
AND THE LIST GOES ON SO I NEED
YOU TO TELL ME BECAUSE
CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW WINTERS THERE INSTEAD
OF CALIFORNIA. WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PATIENTS IN.
AT ARE PROTECTED.
.
WHAT DOES IT TAKE SO LONG? FOR
THESE OCCURRENCES TAKE PLACE FOR
ONE.
AND DO LICENSEES WHO.
UNDER BEST OCCASION CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE WHILE INVESTIGATIONS
GOING ON. ARMS WON'T YOU ANSWER
THOSE TWO FOR ME AND THAT I HAVE
ONE FINAL. CERTAINLY.
THE FIRST QUESTION.
BACKBONE TO BOARD RELATIVE TO
OTHER BOARDS HAS FEWER
COMPLAINTS IMPURE INVESTIGATIONS
AND A NUMBER OF THE.
ISSUES THAT. INCREASES THE TIME
FRAME IS THAT THEY'RE VERY
COMPLEX.
SITUATIONS ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
THAT REQUIRES A DELICATE
INVESTIGATION OR A LONG TIME
WITH THE US. DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
TO REVIEW.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE COMMITTED TO THE ENTIRE
PROCESS AND WE DON'T WANT TO.
CUT CORNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
ENFORCEMENT IS ACTUALLY ENACTED.
ADDITIONALLY IF THERE'S A
CRIMINAL.
SITUATION OR ENFORCEMENT REASON
THE BOARD DOES SEEK PC TWENTY
THREES WHICH IS PENAL CODE
TWENTY THREE WHICH.
A IN CRIMINAL JUDGE CAN REVIEW
AND IF THE COLONEL JUDGE AGREES
WILL SUSPEND THE LICENSE AND THE
BOARD CAN ALSO LOOK AT THE
STATEMENT OF ISSUES.
TO BE ABLE TO DO A SIMILAR
SITUATION. BOARD ADDITIONALLY
POSTS ALL ACCUSATIONS TO THEIR
WEBSITE.
THE TIME FRAME IS A CONCERN FOR
THE BOARD.
AND WE ARE WORKING TO REDUCE
THOSE DATES ARE THE DAYS THAT
TAKES TO COMPLETE THOSE
PROCESSES AND WE HAVE BEEN
REDUCING OUR NUMBERS ARE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES FOR
ENFORCEMENT. IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS ON A NUMBER OF THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
SO DID SO.
WHAT INVESTIGATION IS CONTINUING
THE PERSON STILL THE LICENSEE IS
STILL CONTINUE TO PRACTICE ONE
DESIGNATION IS CONTINUING? WELL
IT DEPENDS ON THE NATURE OF THE
COMPLAINT OR THE ENFORCEMENT FOR
EXAMPLE IF IT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE.
OKAY.
IF FOR EXAMPLE SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT THAT GOES STRAIGHT TO
CRIMINALS. TUITION AND THEREFORE
WE WOULD ISSUE OF PC TWENTY
THREE RIGHT AWAY.
IF IT'S SOMETHING I SINCE I'M
SORRY TO THE LICENSEE WILL BE
REMOVED WHEN NOT BE ABLE TO.
PRACTICE UNTIL THE CRIMINAL
PROCEEDINGS ARE COMPLETED THANK
YOU.
.
IN ADDITION SOME.
WE DO SEEK STIPULATED SURRENDERS
TO HELP REDUCE OUR TIME FRAMES
AND GET THAT LICENSE OFF THE.
ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC AS WELL.
AND FOR ISSUES SUCH AS
FORGETTING TO UPDATE YOUR
ADDRESS WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
WHICH IS A REGULATORY
REQUIREMENT OF LICENSEES WE DO
NOT.
PUSH FOR.
SUSPENDED THAT'S A SIMPLE
CITATION SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
VIOLATIONS POSSIBLE FOR ANYTHING
THAT THE INCREDIBLY EGREGIOUS OR
CRIMINAL WE DO. SEEK TO REMOVE
THAT LICENSE FROM PRACTICE.
IS PART OF THAT.
.
TERMS OF DISCIPLINE IS ITS
SUSPENSION IS SUSPENSION AN
ALTERNATIVE THAT'S PART OF THE
PC TWENTY THREE YES.
YES WE DO SPEND LICENSES FOR
THAT. OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR NOW. GIVE VERY
MUCH AS AMERICANS IN ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM. THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS
AN ADVANCE. IS JUST A QUICK
FOLLOW UP AND I APPRECIATE THE
SUMMER GIBSON'S QUESTION.
BECAUSE WE SAY THINGS LIKE FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS. TO NINE
HUNDRED TWO LET'S JUST PUT THAT
IS ONE AND A HALF YEARS TO TWO
AND A HALF YEARS BUT YOU KNOW WE
SEE DAYS PEOPLE START GAME LOSS
AT HOW MANY HUNDRED DAYS. IT'S
ONE AND A HALF YEARS TO TWO AND
A HALF YEARS WHICH MEANS THAT
THIS REPORT INTO FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN. TWO AND A HALF YEARS
MEANS THAT SOMEONE WHO WAS
ACCUSED AT THE TIME THIS NUMBER
CAME OUT MAY STILL.
THE PROCESSING.
AND THEN THE AVERAGE IS
COMPLETE DISPLAY AT
INVESTIGATIONS. WE SAY A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED AND. ELEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO YOU'RE
TALKING TWO POINT NINE SEVEN
YEARS TO OVER THREE YEARS.
AND IT WORKED OUT SO I I ENDED
BECAUSE WE SAY NUMBER OF DAYS I
MEAN SOMEBODY JUST GET LOST AT
HOW MANY HUNDRED DAYS LET'S JUST
BE VERY CLEAR. OVER THREE YEARS
DID SO WERE WE DOING TO SHRINK
THAT I MEAN IS ACCEPTABLE TO BE
THREE YEARS.
IT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE FROM A
PUBLIC PERSON TRACTION
STANDPOINT.
AND THAT THE AVERAGE THAT IS
THE OTHER HALF OF THEM ARE
LONGER EXACTLY RIGHT AND A
NUMBER OF OUR SMALLER AGAIN
THESE ARE LOWER NUMBER OF CASES
ARE AVERAGE DOES GET AFFECTED BY
THAT BUT IT IS OUR AVERAGE.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO IMPROVE
THOSE TIME AS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE AND WITH A DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION.
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
REDUCE THAT TIME WHAT'S WHAT'S
THE GOAL HOW LONG SHOULD BE.
AS LOW AS POSSIBLE I BELIEVE OUR
TARGETS MODERN FORTY DAYS.
BUT SAID I BELIEVE THE TARGET
DATE IS FIVE IRON FORTY DAYS
FROM START RECEIVING COMPLAINTS
TO.
YEARS IS THAT THAT WOULD BE
JUST OVER. ONE AND A HALF YES
OKAY SO DOES THAT STILL A YEAR
AND A HALF AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY
MUCH BUT ME MUCH GREATER
IMPROVEMENT AND THE NUMBERS WE
HAVE HERE CERTAINLY AND. IF I
MAY BRING ATTENTION THE FACT
THAT IT HAS TO GO THROUGH THIS
OCCASION THAT HAS TO GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AND HEARINGS.
AS WELL SO THAT DOES TACK ON
MORE TIME BUT IT IS A COMPLETE
AND OPEN PROCESS IS THERE A WAY
TO GET A. BREAK DOWN TO REALIZE
THERE'S A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
SO SOMEONE TAKE LONGER AND
OTHERS AS A WAY TO DO MORE OF A
BREAK DOWN LIKE HOW MANY PEOPLE
DO YOU HAVE THAT WHICH TYPES
BECAUSE CERTAINLY.
I MEAN THERE'S CERTAIN CERTAIN
ONES IN YOUR PRIOR PRIORITIZING
CERTAIN ONES I MEAN RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE THESE AVERAGES IS THERE A
WAY TO SAY OKAY YOU KNOW SOME
ARE MINOR AND DEBT AND BUT THAT
MAJOR ONES ETCETERA AND I SEE
SOME TO REQUIRE MORE
INVESTIGATION WE HAVE TO. DO
PROCESSO I'M REALIZE THERE'S A
TIME ASSOCIATED WITH THAT TOO.
THAT THING THAT MIGHT BE HELPFUL
TO. HAVE A BETTER REFLECTION OF
WHAT YOU ARE DOING WHAT THE
REASONABLE GOALS ARE. ETCETERA.
BECAUSE JUST HAVING THIS SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S PRETTY ONE SO BUT YOU
KNOW I KNOW ALSO KNOW THAT IT'S
A SERIOUS ISSUE AND NEEDS TO
CONSIDER ONE DESTINATION IT
TAKES TIME. BUT. WE WILL LOOK
INTO ADDITIONAL REPORTING THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE THE COMMITTEES
UPON INDIVIDUAL A DISCIPLINARY
CASES. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
CONSULTANTS TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
OF QUESTIONS EVENLY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS AND FOR THE GOOD
WORK THAT I THINK YOU'VE BEEN
DOING OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS TO
KIND OF BRING THINGS. CLOSER TO
WHAT I THINK WE.
WOULD FEEL WOULD BE. ACCEPTABLE
STANDARDS AND AND.
EXCELLENT STANDARDS WITH WHICH
I THINK YOU YOU WANT TO PERFORM
THE. THE BOARD WITH THE ONE
QUESTION THAT CAME TO MIND OVER
ISSUE TWELVE AND THIS IS THE ONE
WHERE.
IF YOU RECALL DEALS WITH THE.
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED BY NON ACUPUNCTURISTS.
BY OTHER PROFESSIONS.
AND.
IT SEEMS TO BE AN ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THEIR TRAINING FOR THAT
THEY HAVE THE TRAINING AND
COMPETENCY TO DO THAT HAVE YOU
REACHED OUT TO SOME OF THE
BOARDS. OF THOSE PARTICULAR
PROFESSIONS TO SEE IF.
REALLY FIND OUT ABOUT THEIR
COMPETENCY AND AND THE TRAINING
TO SEE WHAT TO WHAT CAN BE DONE.
IS THEY HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
SOME OF THE SAME TECHNIQUES
SIMILAR TO DRY NEEDLING IS ONE
AND NO.
INDEED AND WITH DRY NEEDLING WE
HAVE REACHED OUT TO THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY BOARD AND CREATED
CONTACTS AND STREAMLINE THE
REFERRAL PROCESS FOR.
INDIVIDUALS PRACTICING WITH AN
ACUPUNCTURE LICENSE AND SO WE DO
REFER THEM TO THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY BOARD FOR PRACTICING
OUTSIDE OF THEIR SCOPE IF THE
PHYSICAL THERAPY BOARD GOES THAT
ROUTE.
AND THEN WE CAN ALSO COME BACK
AN ISSUE A CITATION AFTER THE
BOARD THAT BOARD TAKES AN ACTION
ON THEIR LICENSEE. ADDITIONAL WE
HAVE REACHED OUT TO BE OUR
BUREAU ON. THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND.
CAR PRACTICALLY EXAMINERS BOARD.
ON THE SAME SUBJECT HIM SUBJECT
THAT YOU AND AND THEY HAVE USED
HAS BEEN RECEPTIVE WHEN YOU'VE
MADE THOSE OUT REACHES EVIDENTLY
YES. THIS COULD HEAR THANK YOU
THANK YOU RICHARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN INTO LIVING CAPS LETTING
SOME OF THOSE COMMENTS TO ADD TO
OUR BOARD AND EXECUTIVE. OFFICER
TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE COMMENTS
THAT. HAVE BEEN MADE IN THE
QUESTIONING IN PARTICULAR. TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE MAXIMUM
EFFICIENCY FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND ALSO.
PRACTITIONERS AS WELL AND SO
PLEASE ARTICULATE THE
ACCORDINGLY TO US AND THAT
YOU'VE BEEN AND CONTINUE COM
CONVERSATION WITH THAT. BUT YOU
CAN ALSO GET A SENSE OF THE
INCREASED SENSE OF URGENCY FOR
THIS AS WELL TOO SO. I HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
COMMUNICATE EFFECTIVE MANNER AND
THAT WAY. HAVING SAID THAT WILL
NOW OPEN THE PORTION OF THIS
CONVERSATION TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC.
SO IF ANYONE WISHES TO SPEAK
AND GIVE ANY COMMENTS WILL LIMIT
YOUR.
TESTIMONY COMMENTS TO.
TWO MINUTES FEEL FREE TO COME
UP TO THE TO THE MICROPHONE
AGAIN WILL BE AT A STRICT TWO
MINUTES TO BE MINDFUL OF TIME.
UP PLEASE OUT THAT YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO FOR
THE RECORD.
AND JUST UP AT THE AT THE
MICROPHONE IS FINE.
YES IS ABOUT MICROPHONE AND
AGAIN YOU'LL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
BONNER BOTH CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS THE MICHELLE LYLE.
AND.
DOCTOR OF THE ORIENTAL MEDICINE.
AND I'VE BEEN SENDING. THIRTEEN
OF FOURTEEN ALL OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF. WE CALL THE
COUNCIL OF. ACUPUNCTURE AND
ORIENTAL MEDICINE ASSOCIATIONS
IS I'M BALLERINA. THE
ORGANIZATION INCLUDING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW MY TIME IS LIMITED AND I
AM NOT REPEATING ALL THE MEMBERS
NAME.
AND THEN OF.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THE THREE
PAGES.
THAT'S MONEY DOWN TO BUYING A
SHORT.
SO.
WE ARE NO THAT THE OCCUPANT
YOUR BOARD IS THE. GOVERNMENTAL
AGENCY IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY. AND ALSO THE
OVERSEEING THE EDUCATION STAND
THERE. AND.
BUT YOU KNOW LIKE TODAY WE WANT
TO. KNOW WHY CELEBRATE THIS.
UNIT UNIFY WEISS. AND ALREADY
IMPORTANT IS.
THE EXAMINATION CALIFORNIA IS
THE ONLY ONE THE STATE HAVE
THEIR LICENSING EXAMINATION.
IF THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
BOARD. WE COMMAND. TO THE
NATIONAL EXAMINATION THAT IS NOT
RIGHT.
IN THE WHOLE COUNTRY NOW
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A MORE THEN.
WHAT I WOULD SAY THAT ABOUT HALF
OF THE WHOLE COUNTRY THE NUMBER?
SO IS AMERICA. OF ONE THOUSAND I
MEAN THE CHILD CHILD THOUSAND
MEMBER. SO WINDY I WANT TO SAY I
NEED MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
BECAUSE I ACTUALLY HAVE YOU BEEN
SENDING SO MANY AS CESSATION
THEY COULD GET THE TIME TO ME
OKAY. EMPATH BECAUSE THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT I WANT THE.
COMMITTEE. EVERYBODY UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS GOING ON.
SO THAT KILLED THE CALIFORNIA.
EXAMINATION IS THE ONLY
LICENSING EXAMINATION IN THE
NATION.
THE NC SALE M. EXAM IS A
CERTIFICATION.
THE SEC A LOOM EXAM IS NOT A
LICENSING EXAM LICENSE THING IS
A HIGHER YOU VERY MUCH MISSILE
EVEN TWO MINUTES IS UP.
I'M SO SORRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT UP PLEASE THANK YOU
MORON OR OWNER WILL COME YOU CAN
REMEMBER A MINUS SIGN YOUR PLEA
FOR MORE COUNTY PHONE I COULD
PUNCH OPAL PRESIDENT. I WANT
THEM.
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
URGE THESE COMEDIAN LOOK INTO
THAT INCOME PRE MISSION PIE IN
THE FORMAL SP ONE TWO FOUR SIX.
YOU NOT VIA THE CALIFORNIA IQ
PUNCTUAL PAUL DO NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO FIVE REACHED THIS
HEAT SCHOOL. TEACHING CRAINIC.
DOT IS VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THE SERVICE CAN BE TEACHING
CRANK IT WERE RATIFIED THE
SCHOOL IS DOING WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING. NUMBER TWO IN THE SP ONE
TWO FOUR SIX THE BOWL. TO PANJAL
BALL DO NOT HAVE THE FINAL
AUTHORITY TO APPROVE SCHOOL.
WHAT HAPPENED EVEN THE CUT IF
EVEN? FURTHER EDUCATION. AREA
TICKED OFF THAT IT COMES STATUS
BUT WILL PUT THE CALIFORNIA. IN
A VERY BAD. POSITION.
AND IT MAY HAPPEN YOU MAY NOT
HAPPEN BUT WHAT HAPPENS IF WE
LET THE CRAZIEST KULA. STUDENT
CANNOT PAY THE STUDENT ALL THEY
MEET THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENT SO
OF A GOVERNMENT AGENCY. A COUPON
SHOWBOAT SHOOT HAVE FINAL
AUTHORITY TO APPROVE THE SCHOOL.
ABOVE ANY AGENCY.
AND THE FIRST REGARDING THE
NATIONAL IS THAT. I'VE BEEN RICH
FIVE YOU SEE OVER THIRTY FIVE
SCHOOL IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT HOW DOES THIS COURT MAY WONG
CALIFORNIA APPROVAL BECAUSE THEY
WANNA GRADUATE STUDENT COME TO
CALIFORNIA TAKE THAT YOU SENT
AND PRACTICE IN THE SCHOOL. AND
EACH STATE HAS LET THE FRONT
FENDER. PARTY FORNEY OUT LESS OF
A COUPON SURE IF ONE OR THE
SEVEN PHYSICIAN IN WHAT KIND OF
SHIPMENT. BOTHER HIGH POINT IN
THE OUT OF STATE WHAT HAPPENED
RELATE DON'T HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT A
REPLICATION CALIFORNIA. HOLDING
SICK BACON SAID OPTUS EDUCATING
SPENDER AND DO THE TRAINING AND
PUT THE ELIMINATION MAKING
MISTER LEE.
THANK THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS SUCK COCK KIM PUT TO
USE THE KOREAN AKA PUNCTURE AS
SHOWN MEDICINE ASSOCIATES AND ON
TO IT USA. ME UP FROM THE LOS
ANGELES. LAST NIGHT HALL NIGHT
DRIVING THROUGH HERE I CLOSE
SEATS IN A MAN'S.
FIRST OF ALL I'LL BE A. GOOD
PUNK TO PRODUCE WANNA KEEP IT.
STRONG ACE SUPPORT FOR THAT.
ANOTHER THINGS IS A SUNSET
RIGHT.
WHEN IT IS NOT THE SUNSET WANNA
SUN RISE UP TO BLOCK A PUMP TO
PORT IN FOUR YEARS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A
NICE DAY.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME SO HE
SHOT ON PARK I'M GOOD AT IT.
NINETEEN NINETY ONE FROM SOWS
BAYLOR UNIVERSITY SO'S BAYLOR
UNIVERSITY OVER FORTY HOURS OR
WE HAVE A GOOD EDUCATOR OR MORE
THAN FIVE DOLLARS IN A KIT FROM
CHARLIE'S. AT THAT TIME I WAS. A
GOOD PHONE SUPPORT TO EITHER
IT'S A MAN OR.
I WORKING AT THE BOULDER IN A
VOLUNTEER WORK AT. AT THE TIME
THOSE THOSE BAILO NOT SUCH AS
THE NATION I EITHER DAMNATION
BECAUSE SO WE HAVE PUT MORE
DIDN'T AT THAT TIME WE HAVE A
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED HOURS
SPENT. ON OTHER WE'RE GOING TO
YOU DID YOU USE THE LESS THAN
ONE THOUSAND SO WE DIDN'T
MENTION ABOUT THE NATION ID
THAT'S IT AT THAT TIME FIND NOW
IS A REALLY DIFFERENT DALE
UPGRADE DONE AT THE. I THINK AND
OKAY PHONE TO REPORT THESE ABEDI
IMPORTANT THEY HAVE TO PROVE WHO
PUT THE SOUP COULD. PROVIDE THE
NUMBER AND ALWAYS SO CALIFORNIA
OKAY FROM TO LICENSING NEEDED
AND HAS TO BE. CALIFORNIA ARE
BOTH THE MEMO BOARD THOUGH.
HAS TO BE GIVEN TO BOARD HAS TO
BE THERE OR. YOU KNOW YOU LOOK
AT ME NATION AND PROFESSION I
PROPERLY MEMBER RATIO IS UP.
EVEN OWNED A CHAIRPERSON ORDER
DIMENSION IS ABATED AT ALL COSTS
THAT HAS TO BE A GIVEN TO
RELEASE THERE HAS TO BE.
BETTY PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION.
THANK YOU.
A HIGH CHAIR AND A MEMBER OF THE
BODY DOT MY NAME IS A TOP ON
SUNDAY BEHALF THE COMMA FROM.
THOSE ANNULUS.
YOUR FIRST SO WE WANT TO POINT
TO THE GUIDING I. JESSICA
PATIENT.
WE DON'T HAVE A NATIONAL
STANDARD. WE DON'T HAVE A
NATIONAL EXAMINATION.
SO YOU CANNOT SAY ON.
THE STALL YOU. DESTROY YOU
CALIFORNIA STAND. EVADE
DEVASTATION OF FOLLOW CALIFORNIA
STAND KIND OF MONEY I STAND IS A
NATIONAL STAND. SO THAT I KNOW
IS NOT A TOTAL ROCK KIND OF WE I
NEED A FOLLOWS ON THE STATE.
SO I THINK THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH STANDARD WE
NEED TO KEEP YOU PUKE. IS NOT A
GO DOWN BECAUSE EVEN STATE
CANNOT DO ARE BROKEN NOT TO
CHINA NINETY SEVEN UNDIES AND
NEED ALL THIS IS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER. SO THE CALIFORNIA
LICENSE. EXAMINATION WE NEED A.
AND.
PEOPLE
THERE'S A.
MAINTAIN THIS LICENSE.
EXAMINATION YOU CANNOT I SAY SAY
RIGHT OFF WHY WE NEED TO TAKE IT
TO. THE EXAMINATION. BECAUSE I'D
SAY SAY HEY WHY AM I ON THE
ACIDIFICATION.
AND THAT I THINK. YOU FOLLOW
FROM THAT LEGAL HOOVER
COMMISSION STOCKY THE OR EIGHTY
CALIFORNIA QUIPU. THEY'LL ALL
NICE SENSE EXAMINATION SO I
DON'T KNOW WHY THIS ISSUE AGAIN
AGAIN AGAIN.
RIGHT BECAUSE IT'S A TOTAL
DEFINE A STANDARD.
ALSO WE WANT HAS THAT KIND OF I
COME ON YOUR BOARD.
THE. FULL VERSION MA'AM BUT MORE
THAN POVERTY COMMAND SO THIS
WELL ON YOU THAT IS BECAUSE THEY
SENT HIM.
THE MORNING.
A MY NAME IS THE RULE YOU. ARE.
LICENSE THE.
THE ACUPUNCTURIST.
ON BEHALF OF THE. HAMBRE.
MEDICAL UNIVERSITY.
AND THE.
HELLO MY.
A SOCIALIST. ASSOCIATES SHOULD.
I SUPPORTED. THE CALIFORNIA
LICENSE BECAUSE THEM. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME'S THAT EXCEED A HARD
SAYING. I MEAN. ALLIES IS THERE
A KEY PUNK TO SUCCESS IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
ARMY REPRESENTATIVES WHO ARE.
CALIFORNIA. AND.
AND HE PUMPED UP ALREADY.
MEDICINE ASSOCIATION.
I'M SUPPORT CALIFORNIA.
IT IS DONE THANK YOU.
HI. I'M ALONE LINCOLN TOWN. I'M
FROM IS THE KIND OF THING THE
OCCUPYING TERRA ARE INTO A
CESSATION.
UP TO DATE I'VE BEEN IN BECAUSE
IT'S HURTING ISAAC I SING SO IS
OR IN PUNTING TOO. BECAUSE I
COULD POINT OUT CALIFORNIA UPON
CHARM BALD IS NECESSARY FOR ALL
COMPANY ON EVERYONE.
BECAUSE IT IS A HUNTER IN
AMERICA EARLIER ON.
FROM WAS THE. CHAIRMAN OF OUR
FOOD TENA. HELPING ON THE
PRAYING OUT A COME TO FROM THE
TENANT TO AMERICA. SO IS THE.
AALIYAH IS A COMPANY OUT. OF THE
MAYBE A THE BALL OF THE NOW AND
THERE'S A.
IS A HUNTER SO IS THIS THE END
OF MAY BE AND THE CITY OF. OFFER
THE US.
SO IS THE MONUMENT PATIENTS
UNDER HAVE THESE THE.
AS I CAN TELL YOU THERE ARE GOOD
AT IS THE NEED TO HAVE A MINIMUM
OF PATIENTS.
SO I THINK SO OF.
IS THE KIND. PUNCTURE BALLED UP.
UNDER THE. EXACT IN THE NATION.
SO A COUNTER.
OF.
AND I CAN TELL.
CONTACT THE LACING HIS INNATE. I
I.
PLACE IN.
IS THAT I THINK OF THE NATION IS
THE RUN THAT STORY IF I EVER
WHAT SO I SUGGEST.
SO THANK YOU.
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING I'M DOCTOR MICHAEL
FOX AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURISTS AS THE
ASIAN AND I PRACTICE IN LOS
ANGELES. I HAVE THREE ISSUES AND
AND AND ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT'S VERY CRUCIAL TO US WHEN
WE. THE CALIFORNIA I COULD POST
A PUNCTURE ASSOCIATION IS VERY
STRONGLY WORKING TOWARD
UNIFICATION OF THE STRAIGHT
ORGANIZATION WHEN YOU FOCUS. TOO
MUCH ON UNIFICATION YOU CREATE
COMPROMISE WHEN YOU COME WHEN
YOU FOCUS TOO MUCH ON DIVERSITY.
YOU CREATE DIVISIONS.
WHAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON IS
CONNECTEDNESS?
THIS NCCA WANTED AN EXAM IS I
BELIEVE IMPORTANT FOR US TO TO
REACH OUT AND ADOPT AS A NATION
WIDE STANDARD WE NEED. OUR NEW
ACUPUNCTURISTS ARE NEW.
FOLKS COMING AND THAT COMPORTS
THEIR LICENSE TO MANY DIFFERENT
PLACES. ON THE ISSUE OF
CONNECTEDNESS.
I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT AN
APPARENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
AND MANY OF MY MEMBERS OF ASKED
ME TO TO BRING THIS TO THE ISSUE
SO I'M GOING TO QUICKLY WRAP UP
HERE.
OUR CURRENT CHAIR DOCUMENT
TECHIE.
IT IS LINKED TO THE HIGHLAND
HOSPITAL INTEGRATIVE MEDICINE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM.
AND SHE HAS SPOKEN OUT AND
DOCTOR MA HAS SPOKEN OUT SEVERAL
TIMES IN OPPOSITION TO THE KALE.
SORRY IN IN OPPOSITION TO THE
NCC A WHEN EXAM. AND IN FAVOR OF
RETAINING THE KALE EXAM THAT
DOCUMENT TAKE YEARS NOT RECUSED
HERSELF FROM ANY OF THESE
DISCUSSIONS. WE FIND THIS
CONCERNING AND THE USE OF.
CURRENTS OF LEGAL ISSUES AND
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AND WE
WOULD LIKE THAT TO BE LOOKED AT.
OUR MAIN THING RIGHT NOW IS
UNIFICATION WE HAVE TO COME
TOGETHER AND TO COMING TOGETHER.
IS GONNA RE REQUIRE US ALL TO
LOOK AT DIFFERENT THINGS WERE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF RINGING
OUR ACUPUNCTURE TOGETHER SO THAT
OUR LEGISLATORS. CAN HAVE ONE
VOICE AND FIGURE OUT. WHAT'S
BEST FOR OUR STATE AND FOR OUR
PATIENTS THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S YOUNG KIM I'M
REPRESENTING KOREAN OKAY I COULD
CONTROL PHYSICIAN.
I'VE BEEN ATTENDING CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE COALITION MEETING
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND UP
UNTIL TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IN
STATE DIVIDED. INTO DIFFERENT
POSITION ON AND CJ OEM. AND THE
I'M NOW I AM I WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT THERE ARE ABOUT FORTY
PERCENT A. LICENSED
ACUPUNCTURIST INNATE IN THE US
DECIDING PRACTICING IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN. WE ARE
UPHOLDING THE HIGHEST STANDARD
OF EDUCATION AND TRAINING. AND I
WANT A STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PROFESSION NOT THE.
NATIONWIDE FITNESS. STANDARD
THANK YOU.
GOOD MONEY L. HONORABLE. BP SAID
AND THE. FAMILY THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH FOR HEARING OUR VOICE.
THE.
I'M FROM THE LOS ANGELES AREA
AND WE DROVE ALL WEEK YESTERDAY
FROM SAN DIEGO TO HEAR THIS
MONEY.
BECAUSE THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
SAID TO US. TO EXPRESS OUR
ASSOCIATIONS THE VOICE SOUL
HUIZENGA. BEFORE WE TALKING
ABOUT TO DIAL ONE EXAM THE ISSUE
WE SHOULD TAKE WE SHOULD LOOK
THINK ABOUT THAT WHAT. THE GOAL
OF WHAT THE PROFESSION WANT TO
GO WHAT'S THE LEVEL CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU PUNCH A PROFESSION
SHOULD THE BEAT. OF EITHER
HISTORICALLY CALIFORNIA AND YOU
PUNCH A PROFESSION IS LEADING
THE COUNTRY SOUL. WON THE KIND
THE EXAM CAN.
MEET THESE OF SIN THAT SO THAT'S
A QUESTION FOR. ALL OF US TO
THINK ABOUT.
AND THE SECOND THAT.
I KNOW THE ACUPUNCTURE. IS MORE
POPULAR THAN FORTY YEARS AGO. IN
TUCSON THE STREET A YOU NEED TO.
SEND THE BILL FOR ACUPUNCTURE
THE EDUCATION TO BE FALSE ON THE
HOUR A DOCTORAL LEVEL ENGINES.
ANALYZES SOUL.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY YEARS LATER
WHERE ARE WE I'M SO NOW THE
JOINT COMMISSION. ACCREDITS. ALL
THE HOSPITAL ABOUT FOR THE
HOSPITAL ZERO CRY THAT. ALL THE
PAIN TREATMENT HAS ALTERNATIVE
MEDICINE INCLUDE ACUPUNCTURE SO
CAN ARE WE READY TO GO TO
HOSPITAL TO GO TO THE MAINSTREAM
AND MENACING. THAT'S ALL THE
QUESTIONS MULTI PART AND THEN
THE EXAM THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME'S TOM KILL I'M A
LICENSED ACUPUNCTURIST.
I AM CHIEF RESIDENT OF TCM AT
HIGHLAND HOSPITAL IN OAKLAND.
AND I AM ON THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS VICE CHAIR FOR THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CHINESE
MEDICINE.
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CHINESE
MEDICINE SUPPORTS THE CALIFORNIA
ARCHITECTURE BOARD. AND BELIEVES
THAT VITAL TO PROTECT THE SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF CONSUMERS AND
THE OCCUPANT YOUR PROFESSION.
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURISTS
PURPOSE IS TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS FROM INCOMPETENT IN
FRAUDULENT DOCUMENTS YOUR
PRACTICE.
FOR LICENSING AND READ
REGULATION OF ACUPUNCTURISTS. BY
ENFORCING THE CALIFORNIA
OCCUPANT YOUR LICENSE OR ACT.
CALIFORNIA COULD PUNCH YOUR
COMMUNITY IS THE SIZE OF ALL THE
OTHER STATES PUT TOGETHER.
IN REGARDS TO THE LICENSING
EXAM.
THE JANUARY TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
AFFAIRS OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
EXAMINATION SERVICES OPUS.
REVIEWED BOTH THE KALE AND THE
NCC A WARM EXAMS.
FOUND THAT THE BOTH EXAMS ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY COMPATIBLE AND
THEIR ABILITY TO TEST ENTRY
LEVEL ACUPUNCTURISTS.
OTHER THAN CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
LAWS REGULATIONS.
THE OPUS REVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA THE KALE STATED AND I
QUOTE.
THE TEST COVERS THE GENERAL
AREAS OF OCCUPANTS YOUR
PRACTICE.
RELEVANT TO ENTRY LEVEL
LICENSURE IN CALIFORNIA OCCUPANT
YOUR PRACTICE. RELATED TO
CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC LAWS RULES
AND REGULATIONS.
THE NC SALE M. EXAM DOES NOT. IN
OTHER WORDS WE HAVE A PERFECTLY
GOOD FUNCTIONING TESTING THE
KILL.
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT
REPLACING THE KALE WITH THE NC
SALEM WILL FURTHER THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARDS
DUTY.
OF PROTECTING CONSUMERS FROM
INCOMPETENT DOCUMENTS OR
PRACTICE.
THEREFORE.
WE RECOMMEND THE CONTINUANCE OF
THE KILL EXAM. WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
RAMP UP ITS EFFORTS.
TO MAKE THE KILL MORE ACCESSIBLE
FOR COMPUTER BASED ELECTRONIC
TESTING.
THIS UPGRADE TO RESULT IN COST
SAVINGS AND BE MUTUALLY
CONVENIENT FOR BOTH THE
CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURE BOARD AND
ITS CANDIDATES.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY SOME SIXTEEN
STATES THAT OFFER RECIPROCITY
FOR CALIFORNIA ACUPUNCTURISTS.
SINCE THE OPUS REPORT SHOWS THAT
THE KALE IN THE NCC A WHIM EXAM
ARE FUNDAMENTALLY COMPATIBLE.
WE URGE THE CALIFORNIA OCCUPANTS
ABOARD TO WORK WITH OTHER STATES
NATIONALLY.
TO MAKE RECIPROCITY AGREEMENTS
FOR PORTABILITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA OCCUPANT YOUR LICENSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RAW
ADCOCK I'M A LICENSED
ACUPUNCTURIST I PRACTICE IN
PEDIATRIC ONCOLOGY FOR UCSF.
I DO RESEARCH AND CLINICAL WORK
THERE I'M ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ORIENTAL MEDICAL FOR FASHION.
OUR PROFESSION IS AMAZING LOOK
AT THE DIVERSITY IN THIS ROOM IT
DOES REPRESENT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES AND ALSO THE GREAT
GIFT THAT WE HAVE IN THE
PROFESSION OF ACUPUNCTURE. IT
PRESENTS UNIQUE CHALLENGES FOR
US AND HOW WE WORK WITH
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES MANY
DIFFERENT CULTURES AND INTEGRATE
THAT INTO A VERY COMPLICATED BY
A MEDICAL SYSTEM. I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE EXAMS
THAT'S THE CERTAINLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR US TO WORK OUT BUT I
ALSO NOTICE A FEW THINGS THAT I
THINK OUR PROFESSION FACES.
NUMBER ONE HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO
DELIVER LOW COST AFFORDABLE CARE
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE AN ANSWER TO THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES
OF HEALTH HAS. STATED THAT
ACUPUNCTURE IS A SOLUTION TO
OPIATE ADDICTION AND PAIN
MANAGEMENT. OUR PROFESSION IS
GOING TO GROW QUICKLY OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS HOW WE GROW IS
THE QUESTION OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE TOGETHER. SO ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES WE FACE I THINK
AS A PROFESSION AND I WANT TO
PUT THIS IN FROM THE COMMITTEE
IS NUMBER ONE INSURANCE PAYOUTS
WE TOUCHED ON THIS. MEDIC HELP
PAY OUTS I'M SO GLAD TO SEE
THOSE REIMBURSEMENTS ARE
HAPPENING AGAIN.
AND YET AT THE THE AMOUNT IS
NOT PROVIDE A LIVING WAGE FOR
OUR PRACTITIONERS IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO WORK TOWARDS
ALSO INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE NOT
PAYING OUT OUR MEMBERS AT THE
RIGHT PRICE PLACE. AND ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTED IN
THIS ROOM ARE WORKING TOWARDS
CHANGING THAT AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE DO THAT. SO
INSURANCE IS A HUGE ISSUE NUMBER
TWO ON THE OTHER ISSUE IS OUR
OTHER PRACTITIONERS USURPING OUR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE AND I WANT TO
WIN THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
HITS IT FADED. AND NOT ONLY DOES
OUR ASSOCIATION SUPPORT AND NEED
THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD TO HELP
GUIDE THE GROWTH OF OUR
PROFESSION. BUT WE ALSO NEED THE
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD TO BE
EMPOWERED TO PROTECT OUR SCOPE
OF PRACTICE AS WE'RE SEEING IN
OTHER STATES PEOPLE WITH LIMITED
TRAINING PRACTICING OUR SCOPE
AND ENDANGERING CONSUMER
PROTECTION. AND ALSO REDUCING
THE ADVOCACY IN THE STRENGTH AND
THE POWER OF WHAT OUR MEDICINE
CAN BRING.
THANK YOU.
I AM TEH ROBIE AND I'M A
LICENSED ACUPUNCTURIST AND ALSO
AN INTERN AT HIGHLAND HOSPITAL.
AND I WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE
ISSUE OF ACCESSIBILITY. ARM AT
HIGHLAND IT'S BEEN A REALLY
GREAT THING TO SEE THAT THE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN WESTERN AND
AND.
MORE ALTERNATIVE MEDICINES IS
BEING.
.
STRENGTHENED AND WERE STARTING
TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE.
I WAS TOLD THAT WHEN THE.
RESIDENCY FIRST STARTED THAT HE
ARE DOCTORS WERE SORT OF LIKE
WHY ARE YOU HERE ANOTHER LIKE A
GREAT YOU'RE HERE AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY'VE SEEN THE
RESULTS.
I PERSONALLY HAVE SEEN
ACUPUNCTURE HELP OF.
PEOPLE WITH THE HOST HER HEEL
PAIN.
.
PEOPLE HAVE HAD THE.
MIGRAINES WHO ARE HELPED AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT GOING FROM LIKE A
TEN OUT OF TEN AND PAIN TO DOWN
TO A TWO OR THREE. AND PAIN
AFTER THE TREATMENT AND THAT'S
AFTER THE MEDICATION HAS NOT
HELPED.
WE ARE IN A POSITION TO HELP
WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS.
AND.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT
NO MORE ELSE. THEN HIGHLAND HAVE
I HEARD MORE ABOUT CONNECTEDNESS
AND UNITY. ON THAT IS A CONCERN
FOR US. PERSONALLY I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO.
.
SEE MYSELF BE ABLE TO TRAVEL ANY
TO ANY STATE AND PRACTICE
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS. AND WE
WORK VERY HARD TO GET THERE WE
DON'T NECESSARILY WANT PEOPLE
FROM OTHER STATES WHO HAVE LESS
TRAINING.
AND LESS OF A STRICT STANDARDS
TO BE ABLE TO COME HERE. AND
PRACTICE IN THE SAME WAY IT
THREATENS.
OUR STATUS THAT WE WORKED VERY
HARD TO GAIN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S HEIDI BARTLETT
I'M A LICENSED ACUPUNCTURIST I
ALSO AND IT IN TURN CURRENTLY AT
HIGHLAND HOSPITAL. I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
ACUPUNCTURE OFFERED THERE I WAS
A CANCER PATIENT. AND RECEIVED
WEEKLY TREATMENTS.
ALONG WITH MY CHEMOTHERAPY AND
IT. MADE A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE
IN MY HOUSE. SO I THINK BEING
ABLE WE TALKED ABOUT WE HEARD
ABOUT OFFERING TREATMENT SO LOW
INCOME PEOPLE OUR INTERNS AT THE
HOSPITAL ARE DOING THAT AND
SEEING A TREMENDOUS BENEFIT FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAY NOT OTHERWISE BE
ABLE TO AFFORD IT.
THE DIFFICULTY IS IS THAT WE ARE
PAYING OURSELVES PERSONALLY TO
OFFER THAT SERVICE AND IT WOULD
BE TREMENDOUS LIKE THE OTHER
RESIDENTS AND MEDICAL STUDENTS
AT THE HOSPITAL ARE BEING PAID
TO. TO HELP PEOPLE BE GREAT IF
WE COULD EXPAND WHAT WE OFFER TO
THESE PATIENTS AND MAKE THIS
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO THE THE
COMMUNITY THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. I'M I'M VERY ENCOURAGED
WHEN WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THE
LICENSING EXAM I THINK.
.
TAKING BOTH EXAMS THE CALIFORNIA
LICENSING IS DOWN FOR ME BUT WAS
MORE CHALLENGING I LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO TRAVEL
NATIONALLY AND PRACTICE. ON BUT
I AGREE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
LICENSING DOWN IS MUCH HIGHER
STANDARD THAN THAN THE NATIONAL
EXAM HAVING TAKEN BOTH FAIRLY
RECENTLY. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RUN A
MODEL LESSONS OF THE OCCUPYING
NESS. PRESIDENT OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF CHINESE MEDICINE POPE
THE MEMBER OF A HIGH LEVEL. ED
TRAINING PROGRAM ALSO I'M
PROPERTIES THE SUCKER. HOUSE
SEES THEM.
TODAY EVERYBODY SIT HERE AND WE
WERE SO THE PULL TO THE
CONSUMERS OF FIRST.
SO THAT THE USER COMPARED TO THE
CHINESE MEDICINE A COUPON TENNIS
BUT IS THE ONLY DON'T HAVE FOR
THE. THE TRAIN YOU SELECT THE
NURSE IS PHYSICAL THERAPY IS.
THAT WESTERN MEDICINE THEY BOTH
HAVE THE. THE HOSPITAL TRAINING
AND THE STAR FROM THIS YEAR.
STARTING COMING TO ALLOW THE
BOSS DOESN'T HOSPITAL HAVE
LOOKED BACK UNDER THE COUNTRY
THE PATIENT THAT I THINK THAT
YOU KIND OF FIND OUT THE CURRENT
LAWS LEAKING ALL OF THESE PART.
I HOPE THE COMEDY THING COP ON
THE THE TRAINEE HARD TO LEAD ME
TO THE HOSPITAL SPENDERS. ISA
PARTED THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
WHAT EXAMINATION IN THE AMERICA.
THAT WE CANNOT FOR PROTECT ALL
THE CONSUMERS WITH BAD THE
PATIENT THAT WE CANNOT ALLOW
OUR.
BUS SPENDER IS IT BECAUSE I'M
BASED ON THE CALIFORNIA STANDARD
THAT MADE A NATIONAL THE YOU
KNOW. EXAMINATION ALSO VSX YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT SOMEBODY HAVE A
LOT TO HELP US. UNITED AND HAVE
ONE POLL WERE WHEN WHAT IS
AFFECT YOU SO MUCH.
HEY GOOD MORNING I'M WAY WAY AM
FROM AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
CHINESE MEDICINE AND
ACUPUNCTURE.
AND I LIKE TO SAY I.
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT SUPPORT OUR.
ACUPUNCTURE BOOK BECAUSE THEY
ARE DOING A VERY GOOD JOB TO
REACH OUT TO OTHER.
COMMITTEES ABOUT THE. I'M
PROFESSIONAL PRACTICE OF
ACUPUNCTURE THAT'S A VERY
CRUCIAL TO OUR PROFESSION AND WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE SOME PEOPLE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE QUALITY AND
THE. PRACTICE OF OUR.
NEEDLING PART THE THE
ACUPUNCTURE WHOEVER LIKE
PUNCTURED THROUGH THE SKIN USE
AND USING A NEEDLE THATS
ACUPUNCTURE. AND IF THEY NAME IT
EITHER WHY SELECT DRY NEEDLING
ALL LEVER. THAT'S JUST TRYING TO
TRICK THE PUBLIC AND THAT'S A
VERY DANGEROUS AND SO I HUNDRED
PERCENT SUPPORT THE ACUPUNCTURE
FOR IS IT DOING THAT AND. I KEEP
ON TRIPLE IS TRYING TO REINFORCE
THE AUDITING OFF THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TOO. AND I THINK THE ACUPUNCTURE
FOR IS A VERY BUSY LIKE DOING
ALL THESE JAPS ALREADY AND THEY
HAVE TO EVERY TWO YEARS YOU
WRITE OUT A BIG REPORT ABOUT THE
SUNSET REVIEW THAT'S. TOO MUCH
WORK SO I REALLY HOPE THIS.
YOU PUNCH A BOARD CAN BE LIKE
SUN RISE OF FOR AT LEAST FOUR
YEARS NEXT TURN. AND DANDY
EITHER ISSUE I WOULD LIKE TO
BRING OUT IS THAT. I KNOW OF
MANY A PROFESSIONAL SPORTS THEY
HAVE MORE PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS
THAN THE PUBLIC MEMBER LIKE A
CHIROPRACTOR'S ALL PHYSICAL
THERAPY. THEY ALL HAVE MORE OF A
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS AND I HOPE
OUR BOARD HAS MORE PROFESSIONAL
MEMBERS BECAUSE IT THAT'S BETTER
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. US SO
DANCE OF THE. WITH THE
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS WILL
UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT THIS
PROFESSION CAN DO. THE BEST TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC AND WHAT'S THE SAFE IT'S
SAFEST WAY TOO SO I SUPPORT THE.
MORE.
PROFESSIONAL MEMBER IN THE BOAT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY MY NAME
IS JEAN GENOCIDES YES THAT ONE
ACUPUNCTURISTS THEM PRACTICE.
A JUST A LOCAL.
SO FIRST I WAS THANKFUL
OCCUPYING TO BOLT.
AND.
AS AS THAT OF ALL OF OUR
ACUPUNCTURIST SO SHOWING THOSE.
.
ALL THE WAY MAYA.
OUR OPINIONS.
SO FOR THE.
THE.
LICENSE UP TESTS. FROM THINGS C.
C. O. M..
I STILL THINK.
I'M I THINK UP.
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
QUALITY.
WHAT'S GOOD FOR OUR.
STATE OR THE.
ACUPUNCTURISTS AND CONSUMERS.
SO THE QUALITY IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
THEN.
IF THE QUALITY IS GOOD AND WE
CAN BE STRONGER THAN. OTHER
STATE.
SO KILL IS BETTER THAN.
AN A CC A LAMB SO YOU'VE KILLED
CAN TAKEOVER ALL OF YOU SEE THE
O. M. THAT'S BEST THE
SUGGESTION.
I THINK. IF.
WELL WE CAN'T MAKE THE KILL MORE
HIGHER STANDARD. AND TWO STATE
OF THE.
TO.
TO TAKE OVER ANKLE WAS CEO M.
THAT'S.
THAT'S THE MY A SUGGESTION.
AND THEN.
I ALSO THINK. WHY THE DO I NEED
ALSO OF?
ATTACKED AT.
THE THEY CAN PRACTICE IT OTHER
STATES. IS BECAUSE THEY'RE STATE
IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
BUT.
OUR SELF LIKE CALIFORNIA OR THE.
ASSOCIATION.
WE NEED MORE STRONGER.
I AM I'M VERY STRONG TO SUPPORT.
TO SUGGEST WE CAN UNIFY AS A BIG
THE. ASSOCIATION CAN BE STRONGER
THAN STRONGER.
THEN THIS SUGGESTION IS ALSO.
IT IS THE ONLY. OCCUPYING TWO
BOARD.
THEN YOU CAN UNIFY OUR.
I GOT ONE. ASSOCIATION THAT'S
WOULD BE STRONGER THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS STANLEY AND I'M
A LICENSED ACUPUNCTURIST HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO MOVE SOON AND
LET'S TAKE THE NCCA WHEN EXAM SO
I CAN CONTINUE PRACTICING
MEDICINE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE STANDARDS
OF EDUCATION ARE VERY IMPORTANT
FOR THE FEEL OF ACUPUNCTURE. AND
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT KAHLER THE
NCCA O. M. EXAMS ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE I BELIEVE BOTH OF THEM
I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN HAVE A
NATIONAL STANDARD AND WE CAN
HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF EDUCATION.
MY SECOND POINT IS THAT I
BELIEVE THAT CHINESE MEDICINE
HAS THE ABILITY WE HAVE THE
RESEARCH WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE
AND WE HAVE THE TRAINING TO
TREAT AND HELP MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THERE'S A HUGE SCOPE THAT
WE CAN HAVE THAT WE CAN.
PROVIDE TO PATIENTS ACROSS
UNITED STATES. AND FOR ME THIS
IS AN ISSUE ABOUT YOU BEING
UNIFIED AND HAVING A STRONGER
VOICE IN HELPING. MORE PEOPLE
UNITED STATES THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS A DAISY NEIL.
.
OKAY CALIFORNIA LICENSE
ACUPUNCTURE. ALONE I WORKED
ALONE. BEFORE YOU STILL BE
REPRESENTED BY A OUR OBLIGATION
BUT TODAY I LIKE SPEECH BY
MYSELF BECAUSE OUR OBLIGATION
ALREADY SPEECH OUTLAWED. ACE IT
AC ON THERE IS A. SOLO NUMBER
ONE. OF I AM LIKE I HAD BEFORE
THE WAR THE REPRESENTATIVE AND
THE SPEECH I AM VERY STRONG TO
SUPPORT.
OUR ABU PUNCTURE BOLD CONTINUE
AND THE ELITE OF IF YOU FEEL
COOL DOLE A WAY FOR YEARS.
AND THE LATE NIGHT AWAYWHAT YOU
SAID TO YOURS IS TOO MUCH WORK.
AND THE NUMBER TOOL IS I HAVE
SOME QUESTION HERE.
SO HENCE THE MAKER OF NATIONAL
EXAMINATION. ALONE I HAVE
QUESTION. I WANTED TO KNOW WHY
ON CONNIE FOR NEON STANDARD IS A
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
EDUCATION.
BY THE HONORS EITHER WARNING
POST ALL THE OR EITHER ONLY ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED EIGHT.
THAT'S NOT FAIR. HE WILL TAKE A
LESSON OR EXAMINATION YOU HAVE
TO BE SOME STANDARD.
SO I UNDERSTAND IN CALIFORNIA
OLD ALL BLOODY SHE'S. WE'RE
WORKING SO HARD IN THE POWERS.
AND THE WORKING SO STRONG
IMPROVE EDUCATION DOLLARS.
WE TRIED TO BE IN THE FUTURE
IMPROVED WHEN I GO FOR SOLVING
CALLERS YOU. ONE NOT LEAVE LATE
TAKE THE NATIONAL STANDARD THE
EXAMINATION IS LOOKS LIKE A
LITTLE BACK TO LONG TIME AGO.
THAT'S HE'S NOT GOOD ON A GOOD
COME THE CONDITION FOR US LES
LUMLEY IMPROVE THE EDUCATION
FOR.
THE MET PROPOSAL IS FOR THE HIGH
STANDARD EDUCATION AND THE OLD
SOUL FIFTEEN. WILL COME UP
QUARTET THE ARDOR CONSUME AND
THE RPG.
SO THAT'S MY OPINION TO THE.
.
NUMBER TWO I I SUPPOSE I'D. LIKE
THE ITEM PLEASE I AM STRONG
SUPPORT ARE UP TO PUNCH OR BOLD
I LAY COME FALL FOR EACH OTHER.
TO BE WORKING IN A WORKING OUT
MORE IN THE FUTURE THOUGHT WE
WANT THEY WANT OUT. ARE DOUBLED
CONTINUE.
IN THE FUTURE FUTURE FUTURES
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE MORNING MY NAME IS MARILYN
ALAN I TEACH LAW AND ETHICS AND.
REGULATIONS AT SEVENTEEN
ACUPUNCTURE SCHOOLS.
I ALSO SERVED AS THE DELEGATE
FROM THE UNITED STATES. TO THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION. AND
AS OF JUNE TWENTY FIFTH.
AND TWENTY SIX THIS YEAR THEY
WILL RELEASE THE DYE THE
DIAGNOSTIC CODES. FOR
ACUPUNCTURE THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME WE WILL HAVE A SET OF
DIAGNOSTIC CODES FOR THIS
MEDICINE. TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
SET OF WESTERN DIAGNOSTIC CODES
ICD LEVIN.
IN THE UNITED STATES WE ARE
GOING TO START THE FIELD TRIALS
ON THAT. I MET WITH THE CDC
WHICH IS GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT. THEY'RE GOING TO COLLECT
THE DATA. AND THEY'RE GOING TO
HELP US TO PUT THAT DATA
TOGETHER SO IT CAN BE USED. TO
SUPPORT THESE DIAGNOSTIC CODE
THROUGH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IN GENEVA.
WHEN I MET WITH THE DELEGATE
FROM THE CDC WHOSE NAME IS DONNA
PICKETT. I MET WITH HER ALONG
WITH W. H. O. DELEGATE IN NON.
IN MEXICO CITY THIS YEAR. IN
OCTOBER AND THE FIRST QUESTION
SHE ASKED ME WAS.
IS THERE SOME TYPE.
OF NATIONAL DIPLOMA CERTIFICATE
SOMETHING THAT SHOWS THAT
ACUPUNCTURISTS ARE NATIONALLY
CERTIFIED.
I KNOW THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE TEST SHOULD
BE THE KILLED SHOULD BE NCCA A
WHIM.
NCCU IMAGE USED IN ALMOST EVERY
OTHER STATE AROUND THE UNITED
STATES FOR THE WAY OF LICENSURE.
DONNA SAID TO ME THERE'S TWO
REASONS THE CDC WILL SUPPORT
YOU.
NUMBER ONE I KNOW YOU AND TRUST
YOU SO I'M WILLING TO TAKE THE
CHANCE. ON ACUPUNCTURE AND
NUMBER TWO YOU'RE TELLING ME
THAT THEIR NATIONAL CERTIFIED.
WE ALL KNOW THAT ACUPUNCTURISTS
ARE LICENSED.
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AS A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
HELP. I ALSO WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT ACUPUNCTURE IS THE FASTEST
GROWING MEDICINE. IN THE WORLD
TODAY. BASED ON A SURVEY THAT
WAS DONE THROUGH THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION WITH THEIR
HUNDRED NINETY SIX MEMBER
NATIONS. THEY SENT THE SURVEY
OUT IT TOOK THEM A YEAR TO PULL
ALL THE INFORMATION TOGETHER.
BUT THEY FOUND OUT THAT EIGHTY
TWO PERCENT OF THE WORLD'S
POPULATION. USES SOME FORM OF
COMPLEMENTARY MEDICINE THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
OF THIS MY NAME IS VICTORIA TO
ONE. A LICENSED ACUPUNCTURIST.
I'M ALSO CHAIR WORD THE.
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF CHINESE MEDICINE.
I CURRENTLY WORK IN.
IN CUPERTINO SOUTHERN. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S SOUTH OF IT.
OKAY ARM I SUPPORT.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
PAPER AGROUND PAPER. PAGE TWENTY
OF THE TWENTY THREE. I DON'T
WANT TO REACH YOU YOU CAN READ
IT RIGHT ON TOP STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
SO I ALSO SUPPORT A COUPON
SHIPBOARD.
.
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY VERY
HARD.
BUT I DO HAVE A ONE COMMENT.
AMY MY TECHIE THE CURRENT.
PRESIDENT. OF THE BOARD.
OF IS ASSOCIATE WITH HIGHLAND
HOSTILITY I SEE I AM
ORGANIZATION HOWEVER.
A SHE IS LIKE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD. RELATIVELY VERY VERY
NEW THE MERGER MAJORITY OF THE
BOARD MEMBERS ARE NEW. I NOTICE
THERE ARE SIX OF THEM RIGHT NOW.
ONLY ONE OR TWO YOU ARE FROM THE
LAST.
LAST LAST A CHARM.
SO.
KNOWING THAT.
I THINK THAT UP BECAUSE OF THIS
AS A DEBATING AS THE.
WHETHER CALAIS OR OR NATIONAL
EXAM.
ISSUE BEING CARRY ON FOR FOR A
VERY VERY LONG MAYBE IS GOOD
IDEA FOR THE NEW BOARDS. ODD TO
THINK ABOUT IT TO EAT RE
EVALUATE MORE AND THEN I'LL HAVE
ANOTHER VOTE.
IT IS A POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
A RUN SEIDMAN PRESIDENT OF FIVE
BRANCHES UNIVERSITY. OF A
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF TRADITIONAL
CHINESE MEDICINE.
AT FIRST THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEN AND SENATORS.
FOR SUPPORTING OUR PROFESSION IT
INTO. INTRODUCING A HIGHER
REMUNERATION BY MEDICARE OUT.
OF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
CONTRIBUTION.
AS IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED BEFORE.
ENCROACHMENT OF OUR PROFESSION.
AND INSURANCE REMUNERATION ARE
THE TWO MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES.
AND EVERYTHING YOU CAN DO TO
ASSIST US AND THAT WILL BE
APPRECIATED.
AS FOR THE EXAMINATIONS.
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN.
FOR.
REQUIRED ALL THE AUTOMAKERS.
TO HAVE DIFFERENT KIND OF
EXHAUST SYSTEMS TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALL THE OTHER STATES HAD TO
FOLLOW ONE STANDARD IN
CALIFORNIA FOLLOWED ANOTHER.
AND THIS IS AN EXAMPLE THAT WE
CAN USE TODAY FOR THE NATIONAL
EXAMINATION.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PLAY IT'S REQUIRED
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THIS
PROFESSION BECAUSE. WE ARE THE
CLOSEST STATE TO ASIA WHERE THIS
MEDICINE COMES FROM.
SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR.
THE PROFESSION AND THE
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD TO SET.
THIS IS THE NEW HIGHER STANDARD
FOR THE NATIONAL EXAMINATION.
EVENTUALLY IT MAY BE THE WHOLE
OF THE US WILL TAKE THAT NEW
HIGHER STANDARD. BUT CERTAINLY
IS JERRY BROWN DID EARLIER WE
CAN HAVE OUR OWN HIGH STANDARD
IN THE BEGINNING AND HAVE THE
ADVANTAGES OF HAVING A NATIONAL
EXAMINATION.
WHAT THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IS GOING TO BE
DOING THIS YEAR? IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
ICD CODES THAT ARE USED BY ALL
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS ALL OVER
THE WORLD ICD NINE ICD TEN.
AND IN THE FUTURE I SEE DI
ELEVEN UP TILL NOW HAVE ONLY HAD
WESTERN TERMINOLOGY.
STARTING THIS YEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IT'LL HAVE TRADITIONAL
CHINESE MEDICINE TERMINOLOGY.
AND.
THIS OUGHT THIS RESPONSIBILITY
IS NUMBER ONE OF COURSE TO HAVE
STRONG EDUCATION. AND AND STRONG
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS AND TO
HAVE A NATIONAL EXAM THANK YOU.
HONORABLE CHAIRS.
SENATORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANGUS SIMMONS FULL
DISCLOSURE ON THE SPOUSE OF AN
ACUPUNCTURIST.
FIRST MALL I I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A FULLY
STAFFED FULLY FUNDED STRONG
ACUPUNCTURE BORDER TO ENFORCE.
THE BEST STANDARDS OF PRACTICE
TO PROTECT THE CONSUMERS. I
THINK THAT THAT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING TO START. ACUPUNCTURE IS
GETTING INTO MANY NEW AREAS IN
THE UNITED STATES NOW THE TOP US
NEWS AND WORLD REPORT.
CANCER HOSPITALS ALL HAVE
ACUPUNCTURE AS PART OF THEIR.
PROGRAM AND SERVICES. WILL SEE
CHANGES WITH ACUPUNCTURISTS
COMING INTO HOSPITALS. THE
PROFESSION NEEDS TO BE READY TO
TAKE UP THOSE ROLES THEY NEED TO
BE READY UNTRAINED.
EVEN WITH A CLINICAL TRAINING
AND WESTERN HOSPITALS AS PART OF
THEIR EDUCATION. THE STANDARDS
OF. EDUCATION NEED TO BE
ENFORCED BY A STRONG.
EXAMINATION WE'VE SEEN FOR MANY
YEARS THE PROFESSION HAS TRIED
TO GET AT OF FOUR THOUSAND HOURS
IN THE BEST POSSIBLE PRACTICE WE
SEEN JUDY CHU.
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL TRIED TO
BRING ACUPUNCTURE AND SHE'S
PROPOSED BILL TO BRING
ACUPUNCTURISTS THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION SYSTEM. AND INTO
THE HOSPITALS WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THESE CHANGES IN THE FUTURE.
LUKE THE PROFESSION NEEDS TO BE
READY FOR THE CHANGES IN THE
FUTURE IN THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE
EXAMINATIONS TO SUPPORT THAT AND
ENABLE ACUPUNCTURIST TO WORK
WITH DOCTORS IN A HOSPITAL
SITUATION IS VERY NECESSARY.
AND I HOPE THAT WE LOOK AT THE
FUTURE. THINK ABOUT THAT AND.
BE READY TO HAVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE EXAMINATION THANK YOU.
HELLO THERE AND THANK YOU FOR
MEETING WITH US TODAY. MY NAME
IS TIFFANY TOFFEE ON THE
PRESIDENT OF C. SELMA THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ORIENTED
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ONE OF
SEVERAL THAT ARE HERE TODAY. I'M
I'M HERE JUST AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR MEMBERS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD AND THEIR ROLE
IN CONSUMER PROTECTION. AS WELL
AS OURS HAS ISSUED REPRESENTS
HUNDREDS OF ACUPUNCTURISTS AND
SUPPORTERS OF THE ACUPUNCTURE
PROFESSION IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE DETERMINED TO HELP
UNIFY OUR VOICE.
ONE TO MAKE YOUR JOB A LITTLE
EASIER.
YOU HEAR ONE VOICE INSTEAD OF
SEVERAL HUNDREDS.
INTO THIS TO HELP SUPPORT OUR
PROFESSION AS ACUPUNCTURISTS TO
MOVE IT FORWARD IN BRINGING UP
TO PAR WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
LICENSED PROFESSIONALS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT AND SUPPORT THE.
NATIONAL EXAM AS WELL.
AND HOPES TO HELP UNIFY OUR
PROFESSION HERE SO THANK YOU FOR
IT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DOCTOR
EUGENE LONDON.
I AM A CALIFORNIA LICENSED
ACUPUNCTURIST AS WELL AS AN
INSTRUCTOR IN CLINICAL
SUPERVISOR AT THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF TRADITIONAL CHINESE
MEDICINE. TODAY I'M HERE AS A
COMMISSIONER AND REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE NATIONAL CERTIFICATION
COMMISSION FOR ACUPUNCTURE AND
ORIENTAL MEDICINE.
AND I HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU I KNOW
OUR TIME IS BRIEF.
FIRST OF ALL A LETTER WAS THREE
LETTERS WERE EMAIL TO THE STAKE
HOLDERS THE OTHER DAY. OF THREW
OUT SOMETHING IN THOSE OFFICE.
WE DID WRITE A. RESPONSE POINT
BY POINT TO SOME OF THOSE
LETTERS. UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T
GET TO A SOMETHING AS THOSE
OFFICE TO LAST NIGHT I HOPE. THE
MEMBERS WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
READ AND SEE THAT WE RESPOND TO
MANY OF THOSE ISSUES IN VERY
GREAT DETAIL IN THAT RESPONSE AS
WELL AS IN OUR. MOST RECENT
EDITION OF THE CALIFORNIA NCC
WHAM A FACT SHEET WHICH UP THERE
IS A LINK TO IN THAT SO I WON'T
SPEND A LOT OF TIME GOING ALL OF
THIS I KNOW THE TIME IS QUITE
LIMITED.
.
I DID WANT TO SAY THAT THE NCC
WEB OF COURSE STRONGLY SUPPORTS
UNIFICATION OF THIS PROFESSION
WITHIN CALIFORNIA AND WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES.
.
THE LACK OF UNITY IS HURTING OUR
PROFESSION VERY BADLY.
THE ACUPUNCTURE PROFESSION THE
CALIFORNIA IS FALLING BEHIND THE
PROFESSION IN OTHER STATES.
AND OUR PROFESSION FACES
NUMEROUS MAJOR THREATS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
WE ARE AT RISK OF LOSING BUT ALL
OF US WHO WORK SO HARD AND SO
LONG TO GAME.
ONE OF THE MAJOR OBSTACLES TO
UNIFIED NATIONAL ACUPUNCTURE
PROFESSION. HAS BEEN THE LACK OF
A SINGLE NATIONAL ENTRY LEVEL
EXAMINATION. IN ALIGNMENT WITH
EVERY OTHER HEALTH CARE
PROFESSION IN THE UNITED STATES.
THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT
TO A NATIONAL STANDARD UNIFIED
PROFESSION AND A STRONG VOICE.
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO POINT
OUT IS THAT I LEARNED THIS
MORNING SOMEONE ALREADY
MENTIONED ABOUT A POSSIBLE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ON THE
BOARD.
AND I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS.
I THINK I HAVE THE SHEET THAT
WAS HANDED TO ME HERE.
BASICALLY WE HEARD A LOT OF
PUBLIC TESTIMONY THIS MORNING.
AT LEAST SIX BY MY COUNT OF THE
PEOPLE TESTIFIED SO FAR SELF
IDENTIFIED AS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE A A CM AND OR HIGHLAND
HOSPITAL. PERHAPS OTHERS ALSO
REPRESENT THAT ORGANIZATION.
DOCTOR ANY PATAKI IS THE CURRENT
CHAIR OF THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
SHE HAS BEEN VERY STRONGLY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT ASSOCIATION
AND IS TAKING POSITIONS THAT ARE
IN ALIGNMENT WITH THAT
ASSOCIATION REGARDING. THE EXAMS
SHEET TO MY KNOWLEDGE HAS NEVER
RECUSED HERSELF FROM ANY OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS OR
DISCUSSIONS AND IS NEVER
DISCLOSED THAT ASSOCIATION. THAT
APPEARS TO BE A SIGNIFICANT
CONFLICT OF INTEREST AND I THINK
IN THE SENSE THAT HEARING THAT
MUST BE ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR ALEX FANG.
I AM NOT A LICENSED
ACUPUNCTURIST I'M NOT HERE WITH
AFFILIATE NOT AFFILIATED WITH
ANY ORGANIZATION IS SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF.
I IF I WAS THE CHAIRMAN TO SEE
IBM WHAT TIME PERIOD I WORKED
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
AN EXTRA EXPERT.
THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT.
ALSO I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE
PROCESS OF ACUPUNCTURE.
LEGALIZATION AND STANDARD FALL
WHILE.
IN MY OPINION EXAMS AN EXAM FEEL
GOOD EXAM.
AND YOU CAN PASS EXAMPLE ENTRY
LEVEL.
PRACTICE.
THEY SHOULD BE ACCEPTED I DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH. THAT.
STANDARD IS REALLY IMPORTANT
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS IT AT
PRESIDENT IN TERMS OF STANDARD.
AND THAT SHOULD BE.
RESPECTED. AND HONORED.
SAFETY MOST IMPORTANT AS A
CONSUMER. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE COME IN.
DOING OCCUPY JOIN ME A LICENSE
AND QUALIFIED. AND THAT'S IS
DONE THROUGH A PROCESS OF
EXAMINATION.
I HAVE. A QUESTION RAISED ABOUT
DOCTOR MAY TAKE HE AND AND NOT.
PUBLIC INTEREST. YOU KNOW.
TO ME THAT'S A RIDICULOUS
STATEMENT BECAUSE.
THEY ARE FEW MD SITTING ON THE
ON THE BOARD AND YOU A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST I CAN PROBABLY PICK
UP ALL KINDS OF CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. WITHIN ALL WITHIN A.
ANY ORGANIZATION.
IF YOU HAVE AN OPINION.
AND THEN OUT OF THE ORGANIZATION
TO SCREAM AT YOU AND BECOMES A
CONFLICT INTERESTS AS A
POLITICAL PROBLEM.
.
SO SAFETY.
STANDARD.
AND RECIPROCITY.
AND. WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IS
ONE OF THE. PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT
OF OUR FINANCES YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH. MEDICOS PAINT AS
ANYBODY KNOWS SIX DOLLARS.
ANYBODY HERE PAY SIX DOLLARS
GETTING PAID SIX DOLLARS AN HOUR
OR AS. IS RIDICULOUS PRICE SO TO
PUT A LOT OF BURDEN ON
ACUPUNCTURIST TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY. NEEDS TO BE YOU KNOW
EQUAL RESPECT AND RECIPROCITY
FOR THE THE AMOUNT OF PAY THAT
GOVERNMENT IS WILLING TO.
SUPPORT. THE SINK YOU VERY MUCH
WONDERFUL THING THANK YOU.
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NEIL MILLER
I'VE BEEN IN PRACTICE FOR THIRTY
YEARS.
IT IN THIS THIRTY YEARS I'VE
ATTENDED EIGHTY PERCENT OF THE
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD MEETINGS. AND
I'VE ATTENDED EVERY SUNSET
REVIEW HEARING.
MY OPINION IS THAT THIS SUNSET
REVIEW COMMITTEE.
SEEMS TO BE THE MOST.
INVESTED.
IN SAYING THAT THE STANDARD.
AND THE PROTECTION OF THE
CONSUMER.
WITHOUT ANY POLITICAL INFLUENCE
THAT YOU'RE REALLY LISTENING AND
REALLY TRYING.
MEMBER LOW HAS REALLY.
BEEN EXTRAORDINARY IN REACHING
OUT TO THE PROFESSION ON EITHER
AND TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
CONSUMER. UP FROM HIS
PERSPECTIVE AS A LEGISLATOR AND
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT AS A
PROFESSION.
TWO MINUTES IS CERTAINLY NOT
ENOUGH TIME TO ADDRESS ALL OF
THE ISSUES I WILL BE SUBMITTING
A DETAILED. RESPONSE TO ALL THE
DIFFERENT POINTS THAT ARE YOUR
CONCERNS. I'M BUT I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COUPLE OF.
COMMENT HERE.
THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD CHANGES IT
CHANGES WITH EACH GOVERNOR WITH
EACH LEGISLATURE.
ON AND WHAT WE. NEED IS A
CONSISTENT STAFF AND I'VE BEEN
THROUGH MANY STAFF TO MANY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS. BUT LIKE TO
SPEAK UP ON BEHALF OF MR BODEGA.
HE CAME UP WITH THIS AS A STAFF
MEMBER AND NOW HE'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. AND IN THE PAST THIRTY
YEARS I BELIEVE IT HE HAS THE
MOST.
DEDICATION AND QUALIFICATION.
TO REALLY LISTEN TO THE CONCERNS
OF THE OF OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE HEARING.
A COMMITTEE.
AND AND TO IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES
THAT NEED TO TAKE PLACE.
MISTER GIBSON BROUGHT UP SOME.
COMMENTS REGARDING ENFORCEMENT
AND THE TIME OF ENFORCEMENT.
I CAN SAY HAVING WATCHED THIS
FOR SO MANY YEARS THAT THE BOARD
IS DOING A MUCH BETTER JOB.
THERE STILL ARE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS BUT HE'S DOING A MUCH
BETTER JOB.
.
MISTER PANTS CONCERNS REGARDING
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND AND
THOSE THINGS.
THE BOARD IS DOING A MUCH BETTER
JOB.
THE THE CURRENT BOARD WILL
PROBABLY CHANGEWILL GET AND
GOVERNOR SOON.
BUT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THAT THERE'S A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN. THE LEGISLATURE AND
ACUPUNCTURE BOARD AND THAT
THERE'S A COMMON DIRECTION.
LASTLY. I'LL JUST ALLUDE THINGS
ABOUT IT DID YOU MR MILLER.
THE TIMES THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISHING IS
BECAUSE I'M NOT EVERY SPOKEN.
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHICH IS BECAUSE I'VE NOT
SPOKEN OKAY THAT WILL CONCLUDE
THE PORTION OF THE MEETING. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO. MAKE
SURE THAT WE REMIND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT. THERE WILL BE A
BILL HEARING WITH RESPECT TO.
THE.
SUNSET OF THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD
ALSO WANTED THINGS MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR DRIVING MILES AND
COMING QUITE A DISTANCE TO SHARE
SOME INSIGHTS AND INPUT WITH
RESPECT TO THE. JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
AND AGAIN OF THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THAT TO
BEGIN THIS CONVERSATION OF THIS
AS A STARTING POINT AND PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO CONNECT WITH. BOTH
THE SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE FAMILY
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
AND THAT BUT TO CONCLUDE OUR
PORTION CENTERED WHO WOULD YOU
CARE TO. SHARE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS WHO HAD NO IT THIS
DEPRECIATED BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND AND
THE RELATIONSHIPS THAT ARE SO
NECESSARY FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE
OF. THE BOARDS OF THANK YOU FOR
THAT GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WANTED TO BE WONDERFUL TO
HAVE WON STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION
ROUTE RATHER THAN. HAVING SUCH
FUN VEERING VIEWPOINTS AND OF
COURSE THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF A
DIVERSITY OF OPINION WHICH IS
NORMAL AND EXPECTED AND SODA TO
ENCAPSULATE THE DESIRES MOST
CERTAINLY WHEN DEALING WITH THE
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT IN. THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TO SPEAK WITH
ONE VOICE THAT WE HAVE SOME
CONSISTENCY AND MESSAGING SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WITH RESPECT TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HERE.
ON THE CALIPHATE ACUPUNCTURE
BOARD AND AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO OUR BOARD MEMBERS AND
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER. WILL NOW
THEN TRANSITION. TO THE NEXT
ITEM AND I WILL NOW CAN WE GO
OVER TO.
MR HILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR
LOW APPRECIATED IN THE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE PRESENTATION TODAY
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO THE REVIEW
OF THE DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT LIKE TO
INVITE TO TO THE DAYS OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
DISCUSS THE RAISED ISSUES IN
THE.
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SUSAN
GOOD COMMITTEE PRESIDENT AND
MICHELLE. PEARL BUT COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND ANTHONY LONG.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SO WELCOME.
THIS.
YEAH.
OKAY ARE THE ISSUES. THAT.
GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME THIS MORNING IN THE
THANK YOU FOR. BEING ABLE TO
SHARE SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS THIS
MORNING AND.
AND LET IS KNOW HOW VIA THE
DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE FOR
KING TO THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED.
YEAH.
AND YOU MAY NEVER.
I. SAID I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE COMMITTEE AND A PUBLIC
MEMBER FROM FRESNO. WITH ME IS
MICHELLE HURLED AT THE DENTAL
HYGIENE EDUCATOR A MEMBER FROM
UPLAND. AND OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER ANTHONY LOMB.
HISTORICALLY THE TWO THOUSAND
TWO JOINT LEGISLATIVE SUNSET
REVIEW COMMITTEE COMPLETED ITS
REVIEW OF THE COMMITTEE ON
DENTAL AUXILIARIES AND
DETERMINED THAT DENTAL HYGIENIST
HAD REACHED A POINT. WHERE THE
RESPONSIBILITY WARRANTED AN
INDEPENDENT REGULATORY BODY
SEPARATE FROM THE DENTAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA? SO WITH THE
PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIFTY THREE AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WE WERE ESTABLISHED IN
JULY OF TWO THOUSAND NINE. SINCE
THEN WE'VE WORKED ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR MANDATED
FUNCTIONS TO OVERSEE THE DENTAL
HYGIENE LICENSEE POPULATION AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. AND OF
EXTREME IMPORTANCE TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC. WE
COMPLETED OUR FIRST SUNSET
REVIEW IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
AND MINIMAL OPERATIONAL ISSUES
WERE IDENTIFIED BY THE SUNSET
COMMITTEE. OF NOTE OUR PROGRAM
REPRESENTS THE ONLY INDEPENDENT
DENTAL HYGIENE REGULATORY BODY
PARTS KIND IN THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE STATUTORY RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE OVERSIGHT OF THE THREE
LICENSING CATEGORIES OF DENTAL
HYGIENIST. REGISTERED DENTAL%
HYGIENIST REGISTERED DENTAL
HYGIENIST IN ALTERNATIVE
PRACTICE AND REGISTERED DENTAL
HYGIENIST AND EXTENDED
FUNCTIONS.
UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA IS THE
REGISTERED DENTAL HYGIENIST IN
DENTAL HYGIENE SERVICES IN.
NURSING HOMES RESIDENCES OF THE
HOME BOUND.
SCHOOLS RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
AND IN FEDERALLY. ESTABLISHED
UNDERSERVED AREAS WHERE
RESIDENTS HAVE DIFFICULTY
OBTAINING DENTAL CARE DUE TO THE
LACK OF PROVIDERS.
WE'VE BEEN VERY PROACTIVE IN OUR
REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AFTER
HAVING RECEIVED MULTIPLE
COMPLAINTS FROM PROGRAM STUDENTS
FACULTY AND THE PUBLIC. AND UPON
INVESTIGATION FINDING THAT
MARGINAL OVERSIGHT HAD BEEN
GIVEN BY THE NATIONAL
ACCREDITING AGENCY IN THE PAST.
MORE RESOURCES HAVE BEEN PLACED
IN THIS AREA AND MORE WILL BE
NEEDED IN THE YEARS AHEAD TO
EXPEDITE THE ONGOING REVIEW OF
THE PROGRAMS AND TO ENSURE.
CONSUMERS FACULTY STUDENTS AND
DENTAL PATIENTS A PROGRAM
FACILITY CLINICS ARE PROTECTED.
WE ARE SELF REGULATING AGENCY
AND HAVE AUTHORITY OVER ALL
ASPECTS OF LICENSURE FROM
APPROVAL BALL LICENSURE
APPLICATIONS EXAMINATION
ADMINISTRATION. ENFORCEMENT AN
INVESTIGATION OF LICENSEES.
WE ALSO PURSUE LEGISLATION
PROMOTE GATE REGULATIONS ANTICS
OF GRIEVANCES FROM THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE PROFESSION.
WE PERFORM THESE FUNCTIONS TO
ENSURE A LEVEL OF COMPETENCY IN
ALL APPLICANTS IN LICENSE FEES
AND TO FULFILL OUR PRIMARY
MISSION OF CONSUMER PROTECTION.
WE ARE A SPECIAL FUND AGENCY AND
GENERATE ALL OUR REVENUE FROM
LICENSURE APPLICATION FEES
COLLECTED SO HAVE NO FISCAL
IMPACT ON THE STATE'S GENERAL
FUND.
WE'VE BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT OF MORE
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND LICENSES
SINCE OUR ON SECTION AND WE
CURRENTLY OVERSEA WAR THAN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND ACTIVE
LICENSEES.
IN CONCLUSION OUR COMMITTEE IS
YOUNG COMPARED TO MANY OF THE
OTHER AGENCIES WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
THAT HAVE OPERATED FOR DECADES.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF FORMATIVE WORK. TO ADDRESS
AND AS WE DO WE ARE COMMITTED TO
CARRYING OUT OUR VISION TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO QUALITY DENTAL
HYGIENE CARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. BALL CONTINUING
OUR MISSION OF PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC.
WE THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT US. AND FOR
YOUR HELP AS WE NAVIGATED
THROUGH THE SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS.
THERE WERE FOUR ISSUES THAT YOU
COULD ASK OUR OUR COMMITTEE TO
ADDRESS. THE FIRST ONE IS ON THE
COMMITTEE IS STRUGGLING TO MEET
OUR STATUTORY MANDATES BECAUSE
OF STAFFING SHORTAGES AND TO
ADDRESS THAT IS OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. ANTHONY LONG.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
OUR STRUGGLES WITH A STAFFING
ARE VERY WELL KNOWN TO US AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
TRY AND OBTAIN ADDITIONAL STUFF.
AND. GOING FORWARD WITH OUR
PROPOSALS WE WILL WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS.
SO THAT WAY HOPEFULLY.
IN THE EVENT THAT WE CAN MAKE
OUR PROPOSALS AND REQUESTS MORE
SUCCESSFUL.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAD ASKED US TO ADDRESS
COMMITTEES IS ON THE. COMMITTEE
WANTS TO BE RENAMED AS AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD UNDER THE. DCA
AND SEVER ITS REMAINING TIES TO
THE DENTAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE OUR CHARTER ONE OF OUR
CHARTER MEMBERS HERE WITH US AND
MICHELLE ANSWERED THAT QUESTION.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE I'M DR
MICHELLE HURL BUT I'M THE DENTAL
HYGIENE EDUCATOR.
AND THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS I
WAS PRESIDENT IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TESTIFIED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE DURING OUR FIRST
SUNSET REVIEW. OF THIS ISSUE
CAME UP IN TWENTY FOURTEEN AND.
THIS COMMITTEE ASKED US TO.
.
GO BACK AND CONTINUE TO WORK AND
AND GATHER INFORMATION ON
WHETHER OR NOT INDEED THERE WAS
CONFUSION WITHIN THE INDUSTRY.
ARE RELATED TO. THE DENTAL
HYGIENE COMMITTEES NAME WHICH IS
A DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER AMENDING STATUTE TO
CHANGE OUR NAME AND WE DO HOPE
THAT. SP FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
WILL BE AMENDED TO INCLUDE THAT.
AS BACKGROUND THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT ESTABLISHED.
.
THE DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE
INCLUDED JURISDICTION LANGUAGE.
TO PROVIDE A LEGAL BASIS FOR US
TO UTILIZE THE DENTAL BOARD.
DURING OUR FORMATIVE YEARS.
DURING THAT TIME IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT AND ACTUALLY PRIOR TO
THAT TIME BECAUSE THEY WERE A
COUPLE BILLS THAT. THAT KIND OF
CAME FORWARD BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
WERE SUCCESSFUL THERE WASN'T
ELEMENT OF UNKNOWN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WHEN THE
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE WAS
DRAFTED.
AND THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
WANTED TO ENSURE A SUCCESSFUL
LAUNCH OF THE DENTAL HYGIENE
COMMITTEE. AT THE CURRENT
CURRENT LANGUAGE THE CURRENT
JURISDICTION LANGUAGE A
CONTINUES TO CAUSE CONFUSION
AMONG STAKEHOLDERS BOTH IN
STATE.
AND OUT OF STATE BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T CREATE THE IMPRESSION
THAT THE DENTAL BOARD HAS ACTIVE
OVERSIGHT. OF THE OF THE DHC SEE
WHEN THEY DO NOT. I'M ALSO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WITHIN
EXISTING LAW. THE LANGUAGE THAT
DESCRIBES AND LISTS THE PURPOSE
AND POWERS OF BOARDS ARE WE MEET
ALL OF THOSE ALL OF THAT
CRITERIA. AND THAT IS WHY WE'RE
ASKING TO CHANGE OUR NAME FROM
THE DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE DENTAL HYGIENE
BOARD. OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN THE NEXT ISSUE THAT THE
ACTIVITIES ASKED US TO ADDRESS
IS OTHER COMMITTEES OF THE
COMMITTEE THE DENTAL HYGIENE
COMMITTEE DOES NOT HAVE. THE
AUTHORITY TO PACE DENTAL
HYGIENE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS ON
PROBATION OR HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SIGN FINE PROGRAMS IN VIOLATION
OF THE LAW. HANDOUT TO ONCE
AGAIN ANTHONY MOM OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WILL ADDRESS THAT.
UNDER THE LAW FOR US TO REVIEW
DENTAL HYGIENE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS HAS BEEN IN STATUTE FOR
A LONG TIME.
BUT U UNTIL LAST FEW YEARS
REVIEWS HAVE BEEN RELIANT ON THE
NATIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCY.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS AS A
RESULT OF COMPLAINTS RECEIVED
SOME STUDENTS FACULTY AND THE
PUBLIC AND AFTER OUR EDUCATION
REGULATIONS WERE APPROVED.
WE INCREASED OUR VIEW OF THE
DENTAL HYGIENE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY IF A PROGRAM IS
DEFICIENT OF THE LAW OR
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS THE ONLY
OPTION THAT IS AVAILABLE TO US.
AS A CONSEQUENCE IS TO WITHDRAW
THE COMMITTEE'S APPROVAL FOR THE
PROGRAM.
THIS IS A PENALTY THAT WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD NEVER HAVE TO
USE BECAUSE ORIGINALLY WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD.
ABIDE BY THE THE ACCREDITING
AGENCIES REVIEWS OF THE PROGRAMS
AND STICK WITH THAT AND NOT NEED
TO. HAVE FOR THE REVIEWS OF THE
PROGRAM. HOWEVER WITH THE
COMPLAINTS THAT CAME IN IT
WARRANTED US TO GO IN TO REVIEW
THEM JUST LIKE IF WE CAN PROCEED
TO COMPLAIN AGAINST THE
LICENSEE.
WE WERE SEATED AGAINST THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM SO WE
THOUGHT.
ACTING ON IT WOULD BE THE BEST
INTEREST OF CONSUMER PROTECTION.
IN THE PAST TWO YEARS WE'VE HAD
THE USE THE WITHDRAWAL OF THE
PROGRAMS TWICE.
FOR A GREETING EGREGIOUS
DISCOVERIES FOUND AT A COUPLE OF
THE SCHOOLS.
THE NATIONAL ACCREDITING AGENCY
ONLY REVIEWS THE SCHOOLS EVERY
SEVEN YEARS. AND IT'S BEEN FOUND
TO PROVIDE MARGINAL FOLLOW UP ON
ON THEM.
THAT ARE DEFICIENT OTHER
STANDARDS. AFTER A SITE VISIT.
THIS IS THE REASON THE COMMITTEE
NEEDS TO REVIEW THESE PROGRAMS
ON A MORE FREQUENT AND
CONSISTENT BASIS AND HAVE
ALTERNATIVES. THAN TO FULLY
WITHDRAW PROGRAMS APPROVAL FOR
LESS SERIOUS INFRACTIONS.
TO REQUEST IS TO HAVE THE
INTERMEDIATE INTERMEDIARY
ABILITY TO PLACE DENTAL HYGIENE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS ON
PROBATION OR SITE AND FIND THEM
FOR VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW. AND
THE ACCREDITATION STANDARDS.
THANK YOU.
AND THEN THE LAST ISSUE THAT THE
COMMITTEE'S ASKED US TO ADDRESS.
IS THE FACT THAT THE DENTAL
HYGIENE COMMITTEE DOES NOT HAVE.
DOES NOT USE ITS AUTHORITY TO
SUPPORT A DIVERSION PROGRAM.
AND.
PERHAPS IT WOULD WISH TO REMOVE
THE REQUIREMENT.
TO ESTABLISH A DIVERSION
PROGRAM.
ARE WE REQUEST. TO TABLE THIS
ISSUE. UNTIL WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER DISCUSS
AND REVIEW IT NOW THAT THERE ARE
NEW CANNABIS LAWS IN PLACE. AND
ARE THEY WEREN'T THERE WHEN THE
DECISION TO REMOVE THE DIVERSION
WAS MADE. WE ARE AWARE OF THE
CURRENT CLIMATE ALSO WITH OPIOID
ANTI ALCOHOL OVER USE AND UP
BECAUSE WE DO NOT KNOW THE FULL
EFFECT. OF THESE LAWS ON THE
DENTAL HYGIENE PROFESSION. WE
HAVE DETERMINED THAT IT IS NOT
THE TIME TO ADDRESS THE REMOVAL
OF THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING THOSE AND I DO KNOW
SOME OF THE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS I HAD ONE IF I COULD.
ASK IS THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE ISSUES HOW WE
HOW WE WOULD YOU NAVIGATE THOSE.
ISSUES WITH THE DENTAL BOARD IF
YOU CHANGE TO BECOME AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD HOW WOULD YOU
DEAL WITH THAT RELATIONSHIP AND.
IN SOME OF THE SCOPE ISSUES.
WE HAVE A VERY GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE DENTAL
BOARD WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT.
AND WE WOULD CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM AS WE HAVE BUTTER TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THAT. I
WILL DEFER TO OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER.
ONLY IN LAW WHAT WHAT IT IS IS
IF WE HAVE A SCOPE OF PRACTICE
CHANGE THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO ADD
ADDRESS WITH THE DENTAL BOARD.
IT'S IT STATES THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT SCOPE REQUEST TO
THE DENTAL BOARD AND THEN THEY
HAVE TIME TO REVIEW THAT. IT
DOESN'T INDICATE ANYTHING AS FAR
AS THE DENTAL BOARD APPROVING IT
BUT WE WOULD HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON THAT CHANGES GO
PRACTICE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME PAGE AND
AND.
REALLY AGREEABLE TO THE CHANGE
OKAY GOOD AND ALSO I APPRECIATE
THAT THIS SITE AND FIND. HIM
QUESTION AN ISSUE AND HOPEFULLY
WE'LL SEE THAT IN THE. IN THE
SENSE THAT BILL THAT WE CAN DEAL
WITH TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
THAT AUTHORITY IN THE FUTURE ONE
OTHER IS IS THERE SOMEONE HERE
FROM DCA.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE IT BE
INTERESTING TO GET SOME
INFORMATION ON THE STAFFING
QUESTION THAT THAT WE'VE RAISED
A NEW PHRASE TO SEE WHAT THE.
THEIR INTENTIONS INTENTIONS ARE
AND AND HOW THEY'VE BEEN HELPING
AND AND WORKING TOWARDS THAT SO
WE'LL HAVE TO. ASK HIM THAT
QUESTION NEXT WEEK WHEN THEY'RE
HERE TO. DO THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DEPEND.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION.
I DID HAVE A. COUPLE QUESTIONS
WILL ONE IS ACTUALLY IN TERMS OF
THE WAR AND THAT THE FIVE YEAR
MEMBERS WERE LYSIS FINISHING IN
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WHICH OF COURSE I PASS THAT. WE
GOT ALL NEW REPLACEMENTS NOW OR
WHAT THAT WHAT'S THE CURRENT
SITUATION WITH THE BOARD
MEMBERSHIP. THE. MAN I HAPPEN TO
BE ONE OF THOSE.
AND WE HAVE ALL HAD. OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
APPOINTMENTS ON STAFF EIGHT AND
WE WE EXPECT THAT WE WILL HEAR
MID YEAR WE HAVE A. WE HAVE A
ONE YEAR GRACE PERIOD. ONE ARM
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN BE REAPPOINTED. OKAY
WELL OKAY SO.
YEAH I I JUST WONDERING ABOUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF.
PLAY FOR FUTURE I KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE CHALLENGING BECAUSE EVERY
ONCE IN A ON WHETHER. TERMS OF
FIGURE HOW TO STAGGER.
WHO'S WELL SO YOU DON'T END UP
HAVING YOU KNOW A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE THAT WHOLE EXPERIENCE AND
CERTAINLY HALF OF THEM LEAVE AT
THE SAME TIME. SO.
.
THE THE QUESTION OF IS THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION US SO JUST
KIDDING WAS WONDERING I DON'T
JUST PICK ON ONE BOARD ABOUT
THIS.
THE.
SO ICE I NOTE NOW SIS IS THAT.
DTC HAS CONDUCTED FORTY SEVEN
C. ARTISTS IN THE PAST FOUR
YEARS CELL THAT'S NOT A WHOLE
LOT IN A LOT MORE DENTAL
HYGIENISTS THAT I THINK GREAT. I
MEAN I KNOW YOU JUST WOULD NOT
EXPECT YOU THOUGHT EVERYBODY
JUST A SAMPLE BUT.
AND.
IN THAT AUDIT EVEN ONLY FORTY
SEVEN YOU FOUND THE TENDON FELT
THAT TWENTY ONE PERCENT WHICH IS
SO WHAT IS THE BORDER DOING TO
STEP UP THE NUMBER OF AUDITS AND
ALSO ENSURING. THAT PEOPLE ARE
FOLLOWING THROUGH ON THEIR C. E.
I MEAN ICE SOON PART OF THE
REASON. WE'RE TALKING IS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THE FIELD THAT I GENTLY
ON.
ORAL HEALTH AND. IS STILL
ADVANCING AND WE NEED PEOPLE TO
KEEP UP SO WELL WHAT WE DOING
ABOUT THIS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT IT WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS CERTAINLY
WHEN WE WERE PREPARING. THE
SENSE THAT WE.
WE DID AND DOWN ON THE FOR AGAIN
TO THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OKAY.
WHAT PART OF THE PLAN IS?
WHY DID HAVE? A POSITION IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS. CONTINUING C.
E. AUDITS. HOWEVER WITH THE
WITHIN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
WITH ALL THE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
REVIEWS AND ALL THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE ARISEN. I'VE HAD TO
ACTUALLY READ DIRECTOR FULL TIME
TO JUST THE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS.
AND WHAT I'VE BEEN. AND WILL DO
CAN CONTINUE TO DO IS REQUEST.
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS OUR C.
AUDITS CURRENTLY.
WE'VE CONDUCTED THEM IN
ASSOCIATION WITH THE SCHOOL
REVIEWS AS FAR AS INSURING THAT
THE FACULTY ARE HAVE COMPLETED
THEIR SEE EASE. AND ALSO IF WE
HAVE AN ENFORCEMENT CASE WE ALSO
DO AN AUDIT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE IN COMPLIANCE AS WELL.
BUT IT OVERALL IN GENERAL I JUST
NEED ADDITIONAL. STAFF TO TO
HELP US WITH THAT WORKLOAD A
SOLICITOR STAFF REQUEST IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
UNFORTUNATELY.
THERE WERE THERE WAS BUT IT
DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH.
OKAY WELL THERE SHOULD BE THEN
RIGHT YELLING ME I WILL BE I
WILL BE RE SUBMITTING IT THIS
YEAR. ATTACKS SO WE SHOULD
COMMUNICATE THAT TO OUR
COLLEAGUES AND.
OKAY I RESPECTED BUDGET
COMMITTEES I REALIZE THAT YOU
HAVE TO GO TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND MAYBE THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT. I THINK OF
WHEN WE REVEAL ISSUES LIKE THIS
IN OUR POLICY COMMITTEES AND OUR
OVERSIGHT. WE SHOULD ALSO INFORM
OUR COLLEAGUES AT HIS SERVE ON
OUR RESPECTIVE BUDGET COMMITTEES
THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE IT'S COME
UP W CAN YOU KNOW THIS WHOLE
IDEA THAT WE KEEP HEARING BOARD
AFTERWARDS AND A SHORT STAFFING.
AND IF THE YOU KNOW I MEAN WE WE
NEED TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON OUR
END SO I HOPE THAT WILL HAPPEN.
AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT IN I
WILL FOLLOW UP.
AND THEN AND THEN I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU HAVE YOUR TEAM A
COMMAND SO RIGHT ON THAT AND BUT
WE WE GOT TO DO OUR JOB TO.
AND WE. THAT'S OUR JOB TO PASS
A BUDGET.
.
IN TERMS OF.
IN TERMS OF PROVING C. COURSES
AND PROVIDERS AGAIN I KNOW THAT
IT SAYSDOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH
STAFF RESOURCES I KNOW YOU SO
WHAT'S THE THE. USE OF THE PEN
ON THE DATA BOARD SO AS TO HOW
DOES THAT WORK IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT THE C. COURSES.
TERMS OF APPROVAL C. CORSON
PROVIDERS. AND IT ALSO ASSURING
THAT THE QUALITY OF THE C.
COURSES MOST IMPORTANTLY I THINK
SOMETHING THAT BROUGHT UP THIS
TREND IS NO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
OF THE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
TEACHING. THEIR NOT JUST
TEACHING A COURSE TO PROMOTE
SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO SELL THAT IS TRULY A C.
COURSE SO WHAT WHAT HOW THAT
RELATIONSHIP WORKING WITH THE
DENTAL BOARD. IS AT AN END IN
TERMS OF YOU SAID THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE THE STAFF HE'LL DO THAT
YOURSELF CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO
THAT.
SURE.
AS FAR AS WHAT'S IN OUR LAWS IS
THAT WE CAN READILY ACCEPT THE
DENTAL BOARD SEAT A PROVIDER
APPROVALS. AND WE WE RELY ON
THEM FOR THE VETTING OF THE
PROVIDERS OF THOSE COURSES. AND
IT IS IN OUR STATUTE IS AS WELL
TO PROVIDE TO APPROVE SEE
PROVIDERS BUT AGAIN ONCE WE GET
ADEQUATE STAFFING THEN WE CAN
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. BUT UNTIL
THAT TIME WE DO RELY ON THE THE
DELAPORTE STAFF TO VET THE
PROVIDERS.
THESE ANY I MEAN.
HOW'S THAT WORKING.
IT'S BEEN WORKING FINE.
AND I'VE BEEN THERE I'VE BEEN
WITH THE COMMITTEE FOR SIX
YEARS.
AND OVERSEEING IN A MANAGEMENT
ROLE SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN AND.
I HAVEN'T HAD ANY ISSUES AS FAR
AS PROVIDERS ARE CONCERNED OR
AND ACCEPTING THEM FOR SECRET
OKAY SO I MEAN OBVIOUSLY WE WANT
MORE DUPLICATION EITHER SELF
THERE'S AN ARRANGEMENT THAT
WORKS THAT'S GUIDES ON THE SURE
THAT WE'RE COVERING THAT FACE.
YES WELL. I KNOW THE MAKE SOME
COMMENTS ABOUT.
IN TERMS OF DIVERSION I I I I
APPRECIATE THAT DO YOU THINK.
BASICALLY SO AS A CAREER IN THE
FIELD AND IF THERE IS AN ABILITY
TO. BE SURE ANSWERED THE SAFETY
OF PATIENTS WHILE ALLOWING THE
PERSON TO.
YOU KNOW IT'S WE SHOULD WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THAT SO
APPRECIATE YOUR STILL
CONSIDERING THAT AND.
NOT.
AS WELL AND THEN.
.
FINALLY I THINK THAT.
IN TERMS OF.
I KNOW THERE'S SOME DISCUSSION
IN OUR ABOUT THE ROLE OF.
.
I LIKE OUR D. EIGHTY EIGHT P. SO
YES A REGISTERED. DENTAL
HYGIENIST ADVANCE PRACTICES THAT
WAS ALTERNATE ALTERNATIVE
PRACTICE RIGHT.
.
I THINK WHETHER THINGS YOU KNOW
AGAIN I THINK THAT.
.
I'VE SEEDED HAVING SOME
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE THE DOW
BOARD AND DENTAL COMMUNITY.
HEALTH.
.
LOT OF TIMES WHAT HAPPENS IS
PEOPLE COME IN HERE TO US AND
SAY WELL WE NEED TO ALLOW
SOMEONE HAVE EXPANSE GO BECAUSE
THERE'S A SHORTAGE SOMEWHERE.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS OKAY
FINE YOU'RE ALLOWED TO PRACTICE
THIS AREA BUT NOW WE WANT FOR
EVERYBODY. AND I'LL TELL YOU
SOMEONE WHO DOES WORK FORCE.
.
NOW PEOPLE LIKE ONE BIG
CHALLENGES AND THIS IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE IN AND THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS IS IS THAT PEOPLE
LIKE PRACTICING IN THE BURBS AND
STUFF AND THEY LIKE TO LIVE
THERE. AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT YOU CAN POINT IF YOU SAID
IF YOU START EXPANDING IT TO
EVERYBODY. THAN WHAT HAPPENS IS
PEOPLE NOT DIVORCED ALISON
ROLLER STAY THERE BUT THE NEW
PEOPLE DON'T MOVE BACK ARTICLES
NOT HERE ACTUALLY LIKE UNDER CUT
YOUR BILLY SEND THEM THAT'S. SO
THAT'S A WHOLE DIFFERENT LEVEL
DISCUSSION YOUR JOB STANDARDS
BUT I THINK YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
THINK WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT.
THAT YELLED AS THE ORIGINAL
RATIONALE IS ABOUT TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE OUT TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT BENTON THE CONSEQUENCES OF
WE NOW. CHANGE THE RULES AGAIN.
SO.
SO CERTAINLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING WHAT THE STANDARDS BASED
DISCUSSION IS UP BUT ALSO HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT THE WORK FOR IF
THE WORKFORCE IS WHAT THE REASON
RATIONAL FOR DRIVING THE
ORIGINAL CHANGE WE STILL HAVE TO
FACTOR IN THE WORKFORCE ISSUES.
AS WELL COMING BACK. IF YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR AND OTHER
QUESTIONS IS. THERE A.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
THAT PACKWOOD CONCERN I HAD WAS
WITH RESPECT TO INTEGRATIVE
COMPREHENSIVE A DENTAL CARE AND
IN A DENTAL OFFICE FOR EXAMPLE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS. AND SO ALLOWING
ONE TEAM ON WITH RESPECT TO
SCOPE OF PRACTICE TO DETERMINE
IT WITHOUT CONSULTATION OF THE
OTHER COULD HAVE BE OF POTENTIAL
CONCERN QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT
TO THAT
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT. IS IS
AN ISSUE.
AS FAR AS LIKE OVERLAP OR BUT
THE VICTOR THE CONFLICT THAT
MIGHT EXIST IN AN IN WITH
RESPECT TO SCOPE.
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE WITH. THE
DETERMINATION OF OF
YOUR YOUR ENTITY VERSUS THAT OF
THE OF THE DENTAL BOARD AND NOT
AS A TALKING WITH OTHERS LIGHTS
AND PROFESSIONALS.
WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE A GOOD RELAIONSHIP WITH
THE ASSOCIATIONS WITH THE DENTAL
BOARD. AND WE DO HAVE A REALLY
GOOD. COMMUNICATION BETWEEN US
AND THE WE ASK FOR FEEDBACK WE
RECEIVE IT WE HAVE.
WE ATTEND THERE ABOUT THEIR
MEETINGS THEY ATTEND OUR SWEET
GONE TO CONVENTIONS UP WITH
REPRESENTATIVE FROM OUR
COMMITTEE. WE ACTUALLY FEEL THAT
WE ARE GETTING REALLY GOOD INPUT
BUT LET ME ASK LET ME DEFER TO
ME MICHELLE BEING IN THE
INDUSTRY. I'M I I DO THINK THAT
WE HAVE A GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH IN IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE DENTAL
BOARD.
BUT IN PRACTICE AT THE DENTIST
EMPLOYERS STILL SUPERVISES. THE
DENTAL HYGIENISTS ON WITH REGARD
TO SCOPE WE DO HAVE. IN OUR
STATUTES THAT IF WE WANTED IF
THE COMMITTEE WANTED THE AGENCY
WANTED TO CHANGE. ANYTHING WITH
REGARD TO SCOPE OF PRACTICE AT
THAT RECOMMENDATION WOULD GO
BEFORE THE DENTAL BOARD AND.
WE AMENDED THE STATUTE TO
REQUIRE THE DENTAL BOARD TO
RESPOND WITHIN A CERTAIN PERIOD
OF TIME THAT WE WE CAN GET THE
INFORMATION BACK TO THE DH CC.
SO I I I DON'T DISSIPATE THAT
CHANGING IF IN FACT WE ARE
LABELED AS A DENTAL HYGIENE
BOARD. I DON'T SEE THAT CHANGING
AT ALL BREAK AND THEN TO THAT TO
THAT COME THEY JUST MADE THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THAT OF
COMEDIAN BORDERS ARE FUNCTIONAL
DIFFERENCES DISTINCTIONS BETWEEN
THAT OF OF THE NAME.
WE CURRENTLY PERFORM ALL
FUNCTIONS OF A BOARD.
IT'S JUST THAT WHEN THE
LEGISLATION CAME INTO PLAY BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. THERE
WAS.
CONCERNED.
THE POWERS TO BE ONE AND THE
NAME COMMITTEE VERSUS BOARD. ON
THE JUST WAS A CONCERN ABOUT
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF BOARDS
AT THE TIME IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
THAT THE. COMMITTEE'S NAME
BECAME COMMITTEE.
SO FOR ME THERE IS NO
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE THE THE
IT'S JUST A NAME CHANGE THERE'S
NO LATE AT THE NAME CHANGE AND.
THERE'S SOME JURISDICTION
LANGUAGE OUT IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE OF OUR.
EVER CODE. THAT SAYS WERE UNDER
THE DENTAL BOARD WHICH WE.
REALLY AREN'T BECAUSE WE ARE AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD.
AND I HAVE HEARD TOO THAT WHEN
WHEN WE'RE LABELED A COMMITTEE
IT IT'S IT'S.
IT'S KIND OF A TRANSPARENCY
THANK WHERE.
OUR STAKE HOLDERS HAVE SAID WHEN
WE'RE TITLED THE COMMITTEE IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE A SUBDIVISION
OF SOMETHING ELSE. AND SO THAT'S
WHY WE'VE BEEN PUTTING THIS
REQUEST AND SO THAT WAY SINCE
WE'VE BEEN FUNCTIONING AS AN
AUTONOMOUS GOVERNMENTAL BODY.
THAT WE SHOULD BE TITLED AS
SUCH.
IN OUR IN THE LAW THAT.
IN THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
CODE THAT GIVES THE THE
DEFINITION OF A BOARD IT'S HIS
BOARD BEER OR COMMISSION BUT
THERE'S NO MENTION OF COMMITTEE.
SO THAT'S JUST THE THE
MISUNDERSTANDING THAT'S OUT
THERE IS THAT IF YOUR COMMITTEE
YOU SEEM TO BE A SUBSET OF
SOMETHING ELSE I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ALSO THAT BEFORE THE DENTAL
HYGIENE COMMITTEE WITH THE
COMMITTEE WAS. WHAT'S THIS
INDEPENDENT BODY. WE FUNCTION
DENTAL HYGIENE FUNCTION UNDER
THE COMMITTEE ON DENTAL
EXHILARATION AND SO I THINK THE
CONFUSION THERE'S STILL THAT
CONFUSION THAT WERE YOU KNOW THE
DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE IS
STILL THE. COMMITTEE OF DENTAL
AUXILIARIES WHICH WAS UNDER THE
DENTAL BOARD AND SO THAT'S WHAT
OUR STAKEHOLDERS TELL US BOTH IN
STATE AND OUT OF STATE.
EVEN TO THE POINT OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT ARE CONFUSED AS
WELL ABOUT WHO OVERSEES WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT SO THAT'S THE REASON
WHY WE FEEL THAT THE NAME SHOULD
BE BORED BECAUSE WE INDEED ARE
ABOARD. UNDER IN THE LAST SUNSET
REVIEW WE HAD. BEEN SUGGESTED
THAT WE WAIT BECAUSE PERHAPS.
WITH MORE TENURE ON THE
COMMITTEE MORE YEARS OF PEOPLE
WOULD UNDERSTAND THE ROLE THAT
WE PLAY WOULDN'T BE NECESSARY
BUT WE'VE ACTUALLY FOUND OUT
THAT IT'S THE THE
MISUNDERSTANDING IS STILL THERE
EVEN WITH THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
GOOD THANK YOU AND.
IN YOUR CORRECT FOUR YEARS AGO
THE. THE IDEA WAS TO ALLOW FOR
ANOTHER FOUR YEARS WHICH ARE THE
NEXT SUNSET TO SEE IF. THE
EVOLUTION OF A WAS SUCCESSFUL IN
THAT IT WORKED AND IT SEEMS TO
HAVE WORKED OUT QUITE NICELY AS
WE GO ON AS WE'VE GONE FORWARD.
OTHER QUESTIONS. SEEN NONE THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW OPEN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR THE DENTAL HYGIENE
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE
WILL BE CONSISTENT AS WITH THE
PREVIOUS A. PUBLIC HEARING WE
WILL ALLOW FOR A TWO MINUTE
COMIC.
TWO MINUTES OF COMING FOR
PERSONS OF.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS MARY MCKENNA I'M
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. I CDA APPRECIATES
THE REGULATORY AUTHORITY
INVESTED IN THE DH CC AND
BELIEVES THAT THE CURRENT
REGULATORY STRUCTURE THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN THIRTY EIGHT CC AND THE
DENTAL BOARD.
REALLY REFLECTS THE.
INTERCONNECTED WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS.
THE MEMBERS WHO TOGETHER.
ENSURE THE DELIVERY OF
COMPREHENSIVE HIGH QUALITY
DENTAL CARE. I CDA HAS ALREADY
SUBMITTED A WRITTEN PUBLIC
COMMENT OUTLINING THE SPECIFIC
CONCERNS WITH THE EIGHTY EIGHT
CC SUNSET REVIEW REPORT. BUT WE
DO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL ENTITIES AS THIS MOVES TO
THE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER TANNA HELL WITH
AARON READING ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE
WITH AT TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
ACCESS TO ORAL HEALTH CARE IN
MANY AREAS OF THE STATE
INCREASING ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE
SERVICES IS AN IMPORTANT METHOD
FOR DECREASING THE NEED FOR MORE
SERIOUS DENTAL SERVICES
IMPROVING OVERALL HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND LOWERING HEALTHCARE
COSTS.
SUNSET REVIEW IS THE PERFECT
TIME TO DISCUSS THE BEST.
HOW TO BEST EXTENT THE DENTAL
TEAM INTO OUR COMMUNITY?
THE VHA SUPPORTS EXTENDING THE
DH CC SUNSET IN ADDITION WE
SUPPORT ALLOWING FOR MORE
GENERAL SUPERVISION RATHER THAN
DIRECT. UNDER GENERAL
SUPERVISION SERVICES THAT RT
AGES AND PROVIDE SAFELY FOR
DECADES ARE PROVIDED USING
STANDARD PROTOCOLS AT THE
DENTIST'S DISCRETION.
THE VHA SUPPORTS ALLOWING THE
PUBLIC TO ACCESS PREVENTIVE
DENTAL HYGIENE HYGIENE CARE IN
MORE SETTINGS AND SUCH AS
CLINICS IN PEDIATRIC OFFICES AND
ALLOWING OUR AGES AND THE
INDEPENDENT RT HA PEAS. TO
COLLABORATE WITH MORE PROVIDERS
AND PHYSICIAN.
CDJ SUPPORTS REMOVING THE
BARRIERS TO CARE PROVIDED AT THE
BEDSIDE FOR ELDERLY AND
DISABLED.
IN NURSING HOMES THEN I CAL NOW
REQUIRES RT AJ PIECE TO GET
APPROVAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT
BEFORE TREATING THOSE SPECIAL
NEEDS PATIENTS WHO HAVE. DONALD
MC.
THEN I CAN ALSO CUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT FROM A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY DOLLARS DOWN TO FIFTY
FIVE DOLLARS WHICH IS LESS THAN
WHAT IT COSTS TO PROVIDE THAT
TREATMENT THE PERIODONTAL
DISEASE.
IT'S WORTH IT TO THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE DENTAL
INSURANCE BUT STILL DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO REPENTANCE ORAL HEALTH
CARE. FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER THESE ISSUES DURING
SUNSET REVIEW. CALIFORNIA DELL
HI JANICE ARE EAGER TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION AND BELIEVE THAT
THEY CAN BE OF GREATER
ASSISTANCE IF A FEW OBSTACLES
CURRENTLY IN THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE ARE REMOVED.
AND THEN I CAL BARRIERS TO
CARING FOR THE ELDERLY AND
DISABLED ARE RESOLVED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LIZ MORE I'M A REGISTERED DENTAL
HYGIENIST WITH A MASTERS IN
EDUCATION AND I AM THE EDITOR OF
THE CD HHR ANIL.
ALONG WITH THE SOLUTIONS FOR
EXTENDING THE REACH OF THE
DENTAL TEAM THAT JENNIFER JUST
MENTIONED.
CD HA SUPPORTS REMOVING OBSOLETE
JURISDICTION LANGUAGE FROM THE
BNP CODE IT STATES THAT THE
DENTAL HYGIENE COMMITTEE IS
WITHIN THE DOW BOARD.
THIS IS THE D. H. CC SECOND
SUNSET REVIEW AS AN INDEPENDENT
BODY WHICH GOVERNS ALL ASPECTS
OF THE DENTAL HYGIENE PRACTICE.
THE H. CC HAS SUCCESSFULLY
OPERATED AUTONOMOUSLY FOR OVER A
DECADE.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE FIRST
CREATED THE DH CC. JURISDICTION
LANGUAGE ENABLED THE ACC TO USE
THE DOWNWARD RESOURCES. UNTIL DH
CC WAS UP AND RUNNING.
HOWEVER THE DH CC NEVER NEEDED
TO USE THE DENTAL BOARD
RESOURCES SO JURISDICTION WAS
MEANINGLESS.
CONFUSING JURISDICTION LANGUAGE
NEGATIVELY AFFECTS THE
OPERATIONS OF BOTH THE D. H. CC.
AND THE DENTAL BOARD CREATING
MORE WORK FOR BOTH AGENCIES.
THE LANGUAGE CREATES THE ARONIE
US IMPRESSIONS OF THE DENTAL
BOARD ACTIVELY PROVIDES
OVERSIGHT OF THE OPERATIONS OF
THE CHEC. WHICH IT DOES NOT.
THIS SITUATION ALSO GIVES THE
WRONG IMPRESSION. THAT RT AGES
AND ARTIE HA PEAS ARE NOT
QUALIFIED HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
IN THE DENTAL TEAM. AND
CONTRIBUTES TO THE UNDER
UTILIZATION. OF AVAILABLE
LICENSED PROVIDERS.
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND EVEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. HAVE LIMITED ALREADY
AGES AND RTHK PEAS AS BILLABLE
PROVIDERS DESPITE AUTHORIZATION
IN THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWO RD AGES
HAVE PRACTICED IN PUBLIC HEALTH
SETTINGS AND SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN RTHK PEAS. PROVIDED
PREVENTIVE DENTAL HYGIENE CARE
INDEPENDENTLY.
TWO DECADES.
THE CONFUSING LANGUAGE ALSO
LEADS OTHER ENTITIES TO NOT
RECOGNIZE RT HAZ RT AGES AND OUR
DJ PEAS AS BILLABLE PROVIDERS.
THIS SEVERELY LIMITS THE
PROVIDER POOL AT A TIME WHEN
CALIFORNIA IS SEEKING MORE ORAL
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. NOT
FEWER.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO FINALLY REMOVE THIS
AWKWARD LANGUAGE AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHERS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK UNDER. THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
TEAM NO ONE WILL COME BACK TO
THE HEARING AND THE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR A FOR THE YEARS
NOW THAT YOU HAVE BEEN A
COMMITTEE AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN.
OF WHAT YOU GROW BEYOND THAT IN
THE NEXT.
THROUGH THE SUNSET AND AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TO. APPRECIATE THAT
THAN THIS NO FURTHER COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT.
AND NOW WE WILL MOVE TO THE
REVIEW OF THE STRUCTURAL PEST
CONTROL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
OUR FINAL ITEM FOR TODAY'S
HEARING.
THANK YOU.
YEAH. COME. OF IT.
YEAH IT'S A GOOD.
THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHERRY HILL NATURE
LOW INTO THE DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS.
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE. ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS
WE LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE TODAY.
I CAN SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT OUR
ROLE IN CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
A ROLL AND.
WITH PAST MANAGEMENT
PROFESSIONALS MY NAME IS DARREN
MEN SEEM LIKE I AM THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE STRUCTURAL PEST
CONTROL BOARD. AND AND THAT.
TECHNICAL DIRECTOR OF CLARK
PRESS CONTROL ALONG WITH ME AS
SUSAN SAILOR.
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
BOARD AND ROBERT LUCAS THESE
ASSOCIATE A SIX FOR THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
THE STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
BOARD WAS FIRST MADE EFFECTIVE
IN NINETEEN THIRTY SIX ON THE
BEHEST OF THE INDUSTRY. HAS BEEN
ACTING UP ACTIVELY EVER SINCE
THE BORDERS TWENTY NINE MEMBERS
AND OPERATING. UNDER AN ANNUAL
BUDGET OF JUST OVER FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. THE BOARD MEMBERSHIP IS
COMPRISED OF UP FOR PUBLIC AND
THREE INDUSTRY MEMBERS AND I'M
AND I'M ONE OF THOSE INDUSTRY
MEMBERS.
THE STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
BOARD LICENSES OVER TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND. PEOPLE THERE AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN OVER
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED ACCOMPANIES
THE MAJORITY OF THESE COMPANIES
HAVE LESS THAN FIVE. EMPLOYEES
CONTRIBUTING TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY OF THE STATE.
THIS INDUSTRY IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. FOR HARD WORKING
PEOPLE TO FILL THE ORIGIN OF THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT. AS BEING
PART OF THE DEPARTMENT A
CONSUMER AFFAIRS A CONSUMER
PROTECTION IS THE PRIMARY FOCUS
OF ALL ACTIONS TAKEN BY THIS
BOARD. AND IS THE BAROMETER OF
FOR ALL DECISIONS MADE.
THE BOARD DIVIDES LICENSEES INTO
THREE SEPARATE BRANCHES ARE
CATEGORIES.
THROUGH BOTH THE REQUIREMENT OF
A TEST AND FIELD EXPERIENCE. IN
THAT CATEGORY BRANCH ONE IS FOR
FUMIGATION THIS IS WHEN A BRAND
THAT IS WHEN THE STRUCTURE IS
WRAPPED IN A TARP AND THEN
FILLED WITH THE GAS TO KILL
THIS.
PAST WITHIN THE STRUCTURE BRANCH
TWO IS FOR GENERAL PASS THIS IS
A.
FOR COCK ROACHES ANTS RATS MICE
BED BUGS MEMBRANES THREES FOR
WOOD DESTROYING ORGANISMS.
THIS ADDRESSES THE PASSPORT
OFFICE WITH MEMBERS OF THE
STRUCTURES AND INCLUDES.
THE TREATMENT AND REPAIR. OF
THOSE OF THE DAMAGE CAUSED BY
THE PRESENCE.
THE STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
BOARD IS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONTINUING EDUCATION OF ITS
LICENSEES. THIS WOULD NOT ONLY.
INCLUDED IMPROVE APPROVING THE
CONTINUATION PROVIDERS BUT THEIR
COURSES AS WELL. THE BOARD THEN
AUDITS THE LICENSEES FOR THE
CONTINUED TO CATIA REQUIREMENT.
AS PART OF THEIR LICENSE
RENEWAL THESE AUDITS.
CONSIST OF FIFTEEN PERCENT FOR
ALL RENEWED FORRENEWED
APPLICATORS AND FIELD REP
LICENSE TYPES IS THAT. WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT LICENSE TYPES WITHIN
WITHIN THIS AS WELL.
THE BOARD HOLDS THE OPERATOR
LICENSE WHICH IS A LICENSE FOR
THE BUSINESS OWNER. TO A HIGHER
STANDARD AND NOT IT'S THIRTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THEIR RENEWALS
THERE ARE NINETY FOUR CONTINUE
EDUCATION. PROVIDERS AND TWENTY
PERCENT OF THOSE ARE AUDITED
WITHIN THIS FISCAL YEAR MOVING
BOARD MOVING FORWARD THE MORTAL
CONTINUE. TO AUDIT AT THAT RATE.
THE BOARD ALSO ENFORCES HAS
COMPLETE ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS
WERE NECESSARY THESE ACTIONS MAY
BE AGAINST INDIVIDUAL LICENSEES
OR AGAINST THE PEST MANAGEMENT
FIRM.
ON THE.
DEPENDING ON THE VIOLATION OR
ACTIONS THAT MAY BE DRIVEN.
THAT MAY BE DRIVEN BY THE
CUSTOMER COMPLAINTS ISSUES
FOUND.
DURING INSPECTIONS BY THE BOARD
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
INCLUDING INCLUDING COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS.
THE BACKGROUND PAPER HAS BEEN
PROVIDED TO YOU HIGHLIGHTING OUR
BOARD AND SOME OF THE PROJECTS
WE CURRENTLY WORKING ON I'D LIKE
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO.
TO DESCRIBE SOME THE ACTIONS
TAKEN BY THE BORDERS OF ITS
COMMITTEES IN THE PAST FOUR
YEARS A COMMITTEE. HAS MET OVER
THIRTY TIMES REVIEWING THE
STRUCTURE STRUCTURAL PEST
CONTROL ACT WHICH IS THE.
THE CODE THE THE BODY OF CODE
THAT. REGULATES OUR INDUSTRY. TO
UPDATED AND CLEAN UP ITS
LANGUAGE THIS HAS RESULTED IN
PROVIDING BOARD STAFF WITH MORE
LATITUDE. IN PROTECTING CONCERN
UP AND PROTECTING THE CONSUMER
AS WELL AS MORE CLARITY FOR
INDUSTRY FOR THEIR.
BUSINESS OPERATIONS ANOTHER
COMMITTEE IS UPDATED THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS.
TO KEEP UP WITH MODERN DEMANDS
OF REGULATION AND THE AND TO
DEMONSTRATE THE IMPACTS OF THE
PAST OF PEST MANAGEMENT
SERVICES.
AT. END AND PAST AND TE PAST
FEW YEARS.
THE BORDERS WERE TO LEGISLATOR
TO HELP PASS BILLS TO ENHANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION INCLUDING
RAISING A.
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LICENSEES REQUIRING LICENSEES TO
COMPLY WITH A.
THE HEALTHY SCHOOLS ACT IF
APPLYING PESTICIDES ON SCHOOLS.
AND REQUIRING ADDITIONAL
OVERSIGHT OF WORK SITE BY. A
QUALIFYING MANAGERS.
THERE ARE A FEW SPECIFIC ITEMS
THAT LIKE YOU DRAW ATTENTION TO.
WITHIN THE ISSUE PAPER IN
REGARDS TO THE RESEARCH ADVISORY
PANEL WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER TWO.
NOW THAT. THE CURRENT REQUEST
FOR PROPOSAL. WILL BE SENT TO
RESEARCHERS WITHIN UNIVERSITIES
OF CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES WITH
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT'S BOTH THE STATE
UNIVERSITY AS WELL AS UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA.
THE FOCUS ON PAST ISSUES THAT
THAT OCCUR WITHIN THE STATE.
AND THIS REQUEST IS IN THE FINAL
APPROVAL AND WILL BE RELEASED.
BY MAY WITH APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE FUND. AT
THE BOARD STAFF WILL ENSURE MORE
FREQUENT REVIEWS OF THE RESEARCH
FUND BY ADDING THIS TOPIC TO THE
BOARD'S MANDATED. ANNUAL REVIEW
US OUR ANNUAL MEETING WHICH
OCCURS EVERY OCTOBER WERE
ANNUAL.
MEETINGS DANIEL ITEMS ARE
REVIEWED AND DISCUSSED. THAT
SUCH AS POLICIES PROCEDURES AND
BOARD ELECTIONS.
WITH REGARDS TO UPDATING. THE
SYSTEMS THAT TRACK AND ANALYZE
DATA THE BOARD. THAT THE BOARD.
MAINTAINS THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
FOR ADDRESSING BREEZE.
AND TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
STAFF CREATED A WORKAROUND
DATABASE.
IN MICROSOFT ACCESS.
TO STORE TRACK.
AND ISSUE CITATIONS AND FINDS
ALONG WITH CIVIL PENALTIES.
LEVIED BY COUNTY I
COMMISSIONERS.
THIS PROGRAM HAS ASSISTED STAFF
WITH ELECTRONIC MEANS OF
TRACKING THESE PENALTIES WHICH
MAY WHICH WE MAY PLAN TO
CONTINUE TO USE UNTIL THE NEW
ICE. SEEPED US SYSTEM. I. T.
SYSTEM HAS BEEN DEPLOYED THIS.
THIS PAST JULY DCA STARTED
HOLDING MEETINGS WITH BOARD
STAFF.
BEGIN THE PROCESS OF THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
MODERNIZATION.
AND THERE'S A CURRENT GOOD.
GO LIVE DATE FOR JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AS FAR AS THE FISCAL STATUS OF
THE BOARD OR ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
THE MAN IT MANAGEMENT IS A
CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT CONTROLLING
SPENDING AND THE BOARD.
USUALLY REVERTS APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
EACH FISCAL YEAR. THE
PROJECTIONS IN THE ISSUES A
DOCUMENT PROVIDED TO YOU ARE
BASED ON THE ASSUMPTION THAT IT
WILL INSPECT THAT IT WILL SPEND
ITS AND TIRED.
SPENDING AUTHORITY IN FISCAL
YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. THE BOARD
USUALLY MAINTAINS A ROUGHLY A
FIVE. FIVE MONTH RESERVE LEVEL.
STAFF IS LOOKING AT A LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS IN RAISING THE
STATUTORY CAP ON WOOD DESTROYING
PESTS AND ORGANISMS A REPORT
FILING FEE FROM THREE DOLLARS TO
FIVE DOLLARS. FOR A REGULAR FOR
A FUTURE REGULATORY INCREASE IF
NECESSARY THE TOPIC WILL BE
DISCUSSED AT THE BOARD. MEETING
IN JULY OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
THE INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS SINCE LAST SUNSET
REVIEW SO THIS IS GOING TO BE
ITEM NUMBER NINE.
IS ATTRIBUTED TO THE HOUSING
MARKET REBOUND SINCE THE CRASH
OF TWENTY OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
TWO THOUSAND NINE. IN ADDITION
STAFF NOW ATTEMPTS TO RESOLVE
MONITOR. MONETARY COMPLAINTS
WHICH ARE NOT REVIEWED.
AND.
MANDATED IN PAST YEARS.
STEPH DOES WORK AND IN
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS EFFORTS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND THE
STATE CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD
AND IS CURRENTLY IN AGREEMENT ON
A UPCOMING STING OPERATIONS
WITHIN THESE OFFICES.
THE BOARD HAS BEEN ABLE TO RE
DIRECT STAFF FOR THESE PRO
ACTIVE INVESTIGATION EFFORTS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US HERE
TODAY.
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
OUR BORDERS TO I WILL GLADLY
TAKE ANY. QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE VERY
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT SO MUCH
APPRECIATED QUESTIONS.
FROM HERE I DON'T HAVE THE.
LOOK AT THE REPORT I CAN FIND.
THE PART THAT I HAD HERE IN ONE
AREA WAS THE ISSUE OF. THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS HAS
INCREASED AND THERE WAS A
COMMENT IT'S THE AS HIS SALES
SOME OF THOSE ARE. IS THE REASON
OR RATIONALE BEHIND THAT IS.
COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE
MORE. YET SO IS WHY THE AS IT I
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT SO THOSE ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO THEN PURCHASED
THOSE HOMES.
AS IS THEN THEY DEVELOP AND
REALIZE THAT THERE ARE SOME
PROBLEMS THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
DEALT WITH BEFORE AND THEY
COMPLAIN TO YOU. THINKING THAT
YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR SOMETHING
BECAUSE OF.
THERE ARE NEGLECTED PERHAPS NOT
HAVING AN INSPECTION THAT THAT'S
THAT'S BASICALLY IT ROBERT DID
YOU NOT COME IN ON THIS OR I'M
GLAD I ANSWERED THE QUESTION
THAT'S A THAT'S WHAT I WAS
THINKING THAT IF I WAS MISSING
SOMETHING THAT. THAT THAT THAT'S
EXACTLY THE POINT.
IN ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THE. YOU
INDICATED THAT YOU'RE DOING SOME
WORK AROUNDS RIGHT NOW WITH
REGARDS TO THE DATA COLLECTION
SOME OF THE REPORTING ISSUES
THAT THAT YOU HAVE. IN A BREEZE
LOOKS LIKE IT'S TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS THE THE TIME HAS HAS IT.
AS THIS PRESENTED PROBLEMS FOR
YOU IN TERMS OF YOUR REPORTING
OR SOME OF THE DATA COLLECTION
IT'S NECESSARY.
DUE TO THE DELAY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
IT HAS ONLY BECAUSE THE ISSUE
FOR US REPORTING IT MEANS THERE
ARE STILL WAYS TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE AND THE
LEGACY SYSTEMS IT MAY JUST TAKE
US A LITTLE LONGER.
BUT YES THIS WORK AROUND AND
DATABASE THAT ROBERT HOW SHE
CREATED HAS BEEN VERY BENEFICIAL
FOR. ISSUING CITATIONS TRACKING
THE CITATIONS AND ALSO TRACKING
THESE SELF HELP IS THERE ISSUED
BY COUNTY AGRICULTURE
COMMISSIONERS. SO THAT WE HAVE
THAT CURRENT ELECTRONIC
MECHANISM FOR TRACKING THOSE
ISSUES.
AT THAT.
PERFECT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
WAS LOOKING FOR TO YOU YOU'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE IT WORK GETS
TO THE LEGACY SYSTEM IT JUST
TAKES LONGER AND MORE. MORE TIME
RIGHT AND WHAT COMES COMES IN
THE MILLIONS VERY GOOD.
ALL RIGHTS YOU KNOW THE
QUESTIONS WE WILL OPEN THIS TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS RELATED TO THE TRUCK
WILL PASS CONTROL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S CHRIS RUDE
NOT EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
THE PAST CONTROL OPERATORS
LEND OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONTINUED THE FOUR YEAR
EXTENSION WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH WITH THIS BOARD AND. THEY
ARE REALLY CRITICAL THE
PROFESSIONAL PROFESSIONALISM
INTEGRITY OF OUR INDUSTRY SO
WE'RE FULLY SUPPORT OF THIS
EXTENSION AND APPRECIATE YOUR
HEARING TODAY VERY GOOD THANK
YOU FOR THAT OTHERS WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT.
SEEING NO ONE READ IT BACK TO
OUR HEARING AND THERE ARE SEEM
TO BE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS FOR
US.
.
I THINK THAT THAT WILL DO IT
THIS IS THE.
EASY TODAY AND I THANK YOU FOR
THE WONDERFUL WORK REGION TATIAN
AND AND YOU REALLY WENT INTO.
QUITE A BIT OF GOOD DETAIL AND
NOT AT EACH OF VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED FOR THAT SO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL. LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR HEARING NEXT
MONDAY AT TEN AM.
AND WE WILL BE A CONTINUING THE
HEARINGS FOR SUNSET REVIEW SO
WITHOUT ANY. FURTHER COMMENTS OR
INFORMATION THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU